Whoa, oh, oh, wrong one.
Give me a sec.
I was like, I was all over the place.
I was really all over the place today.
Give me a sec.
Let me fix this real quick.
It's okay.
We still have five more minutes to the sponsored portion.
So it's all right.
I have time for, I have room for air.
I have five more minutes till the, till it's time for the
sponsored portion.
I'm all over the place.
All right, give me a sec.
Oh my gosh.
I got so distracted, guys.
I actually got really distracted because I was like, Twitter
changed.
I was like, no!
What happened to Twitter?
And then I was like focused on that.
And I was like, okay, I should look at other.
And I was like, oh my God, why is Twitter so different?
different while i was i was trying to figure that out and
then i forgot about it's like oh yeah i have a stream today
i i literally had started my stream i was i was so
preoccupied with the fact that my my game looked different
um i'm sorry my my twitter feed looked different today so
for those who didn't know um for those who didn't know uh
twitter has night mode but you could the color of what of
your night mode so the color of my twitter feed was the same
as my twitter as my mobile twitter which was dark blue so i
was just but then because i don't like it being pure black
because i like a little bit of color in there i don't know
it just it's less depressing when i'm on night mode you know
um it's like less depressing when it's like when it's not
full on just pure so I like having just a little bit of
color to the darkness so I have it dark blue so because like
you know like the sky you know like the night sky when you
look out there so I can I can simulate being outside instead
of being a degenerate in my PC room like you know I'm trying
to like you know be a little bit like a little bit of a
simulation of of the outside but now it's pure darkness and
that fucked with me and i was like i don't like that i was
just like oh i don't i don't like that it's just full on
black with no color to it but now you can't even choose
anymore you can't even choose it's like light mode or dark
mode and it's crazy i was just like no they took the choice
away from me yeah like the midnight blue color um anyway so
that freaked me out and i was trying to figure out how to
fix it but there's no fix there's and i was like wait there
is no fixing so so i'm like why change it though what good
does it do like oh i'm sorry did that take too much of your
fucking database or some like what was the point of removing
my rights for dark blue and i like how i'm saying all this
what about me on the screen um i just realized i wasn't even
on the screen while being incredibly passionate about the
about this um just the fucking voice in the background um
all right um i didn't even finish standing up i was so i was
just like it just took away all my attention that was like
the most important thing in my life at that time I was like
it's no where is my dark blue the voices are the voice of
God that speaks because they took away my my night mode it's
shouting into the void um anyway all right it is almost time
so let me pull this up um and then make sure the volume is
Okay, so give me a sec.
Make sure the volume stuff is okay.
Where do I normally set it up as?
We still have one minute before the official sponsored
portion starts.
Okay, 14.8.
There we go.
All right, so, oh, it's two now.
You know the drill.
Huge shout out and thank you to Marvel Rivals for today's
sponsor.
Yay!
So as you guys know, this is the early season preview of
Elsa Bloodstone.
I keep messing up her name.
For some reason, I kept thinking it's Elsa Bloodworm and
then Elsa Bloodwood.
And then Elsa, I wrote like everything but Elsa Bloodstone.
At one point, I wrote like, I wrote like, what was it?
At one point, I thought her name was, was like, I think it
was like Emily Bloodwood or some shit.
Elsa Bloodborne I kept getting confused with her last name I
got the Elsa part right But I kept forgetting what her last
name is Anyway, she's very broken That was my honest opinion
when I first tried her out She is a duelist There's a bunch
of new team ups coming in And also as always Marvel Arrivals
season 6.5 Before we begin and show you all the new stuff
All the new cosmetics Also, eCuppos, we got stuff for you
season guys for all the e-daters and e-couples coming in and
being like oh i hope marva rivals will um will have
something for me don't worry don't worry they do don't worry
you will be represented they heard you not e-couples of
rivals they e-daters rejoice they have you are fully
represented in this game do not worry i shall i shall show
you what i mean anyway marva rival will launch on February
13th, a day before Valentine's Day, and they have a lot of
fun things for you guys, especially for Valentine's Day.
What about single-legged people?
Don't worry, we have something for you, too.
Elsa Bloodstone, sorry, I even got confused.
I thought her name was Elsa Bloodstone.
It's just Bloodstone was just, there's so many
possibilities.
Joins Marvel Rivals on February 13th, and is free to play.
is constantly leveling up and season 6.5 will bring in a new
hero fresh costumes and massive team-up shifts so don't miss
out if you want to support this stream uh this channel or
even marvel ravos please feel free to click on the link
pinned in my chat and on the uh and the banner in the
description below below there um anyway oh yeah and adam
warlock finally he's out of the wheelchair he actually has
movement now it's actually crazy i i couldn't believe it
finally oh yeah and by the way you get to have a helmet a
free helmet all right so so you're like oh she must be
talking about this the weddings no no no this is i mean this
is also pretty cool but like this is not the thing i'm
talking about i'm like for the e-couples out there the
e-daters uh but there is matching there is a special event
the wedding wishes for mr and mrs x so basically you can get
uh you can also you can get uh their wedding outfit so tap
take a chance to win um so i think it's like the purchase
and using yeah so it's basically the where you pop the
balloons and stuff but this is not what i'm talking about
i'll show you what i actually mean
this is what i mean
that this evil is what i mean you can finally go up to your
e-date and propose to her online oh my god you can also do
this for the bro you know your best bro it's like bro do you
want a duo with me and then you can accept it like oh bro i
didn't think you would ask will you be my best Gotta, you
know, gotta marry your homies, you know?
So, bro, will you be my duo tonight in Marvel Rivals?
Oh, bro, of course.
Can you be my duo?
So, anyway, that was what I was talking about.
You can finally rejoice, everyone.
Then we see you.
we see you anyway so other than that that was why I really
wanted to show you guys but anyway let's go into practice
ring for Elsa bloodstone sorry so there's just she is pretty
her damage is pretty strong this is the fallout by the way
this is the so this is her damage I did try her a little bit
um but there is a combo but i don't know if i can do it
correctly let me read her thing again she is also like an
essay i got confused like there's there's a lot okay um
there's there's there's a lot of information here um all
right so i need to show you this this one was crazy um all
right she has dash to her look at her cooldowns okay wait
i'll show you guys i'll show you guys the cooldowns her
cooldown is like look at that four seconds look at that
another dash another four second dash and then there's this
all right so um so that's like yeah so her cooldowns is
actually pretty insane not gonna lie uh but that's not the
craziest part so all right So you see this alt?
You're like, all right, that seems easily dodgeable, right?
In theory, in theory, you would think that this alt is,
like, easy to dodge.
In theory, let me kill her real fast, though.
All right, now let me show you this.
Okay, what?
In theory, it should be easy to dodge.
But, like, I don't know.
Wait.
I mean, it is.
He's thick as hell.
Let me get my cough drops.
that's her oath.
By the way, I figured this out, too.
So, you're like, all right, that's cool.
I mean, that's not cool.
Where the fuck did the thing, did she go?
Where did she go?
I need a killer to reset this.
Oh, there she, oh, wait, no, where is she?
Alright, so, um, oh my god, I need a reset.
Okay, so I'll just put Mag in there.
Alright, so I can shoot it, and then I can bring it back,
and I can still shoot it.
So, basically, you can technically shoot the killer.
character that's in the alt itself so that's very scary i
think like so i could do this and then i could shoot him
bring him back continue to shoot him and then kill him it
can grab as many people as you want in it so like it's very
scary especially if you're on brawl comp um i dps rejoice we
have another character for you It's not like you guys
already get everything.
So, and then...
Yep.
So I can grab as many people as...
And then now you're thinking, surely there's no...
Surely there's a range.
Well, ha ha ha ha.
Let me show you this.
Wait, let me see it.
Oh, man.
How far is he gonna go?
Whoa, that's pretty far.
Oh, let me...
Oh, come on, boy.
Come on.
good boy.
He has a range.
I tested it out last night.
He does have a range.
The range is yes.
But like it literally I think you can chuck it.
If you find a straight line with no obstacle in one map, you
can chuck it on one side of the map and to the other side.
That's the range.
The range is the map.
I have checked, tried it out.
He does stop eventually.
But it's like, it's pretty far.
I don't think there is a map that would be, like, far
enough.
Yeah, it's like, fetch, blah, fetch.
Anyway, so that's, I think the crazy part is just this.
Wait, not this part.
It's this part.
Like, you might be like, I'm totally safe.
But, like, you might not be.
You might think you're safe, but there's a possibility that
you are not.
In the...
The on is very scary.
He does stop eventually.
If he has an obstacle, he's dead.
So, yeah.
You can technically...
You can force the C9.
If everybody's, like, in front of you in the cart.
Yeah, you kidnap healers.
He can...
I mean, you can't...
You don't even kidnap the healers.
You can kill the healers.
Can you kill it?
That is a good question.
I I will have to say it I do not know But I feel like I feel
like if you kidnap enough people like how are you gonna kill
it It has 500 okay so apparently has 500 HP so you just
gotta hope that everybody shoots it but like all the people
that got kidnapped are the people that can kill it because
um If all the DPS gets kidnapped good luck to the supports
on saving you Good luck if you think your supports are going
to kill that.
Yeah, let's hope that you kill it before it grabs you.
But even then, it's pretty scary.
I think if you get grabbed, it's sort of like, it's sort of
GG's at that point if you get grabbed.
IMO.
I got shoot.
It's like when you look up the Phoenix song, you're like,
gosh, shoot the Phoenix song, shoot it.
And then you find out.
you were the only one that shot the phoenix all you know
stuff like that you know silly things like that all right
let me see dash forward your next double blaster becomes a
monster dash forward gaining bonus help and launching
enemies hip follow up with a double shot that prepares tells
you backwards using otter stage empowers your next smoky
snare launch a trap containing the monster diablo once it
becomes invincible and invulnerable Okay, all right, so I
saw this.
This one's crazy.
Fire a living bullet round that splits upon seeking nearby
enemies and making each with a spectral sigil.
Hitting mark targets with double barrel blastered and grants
living bullets deal extra damage to shields and enemies with
bullets.
Okay, she's very strong.
Dealing damage increases.
Hunting instincts defeating enemy caught by smoky snares.
additional higher instance okay so so you see the little
thing at the bottom um the more the more orange you have
this only resets the little thing the um it only resets when
you die so you keep this forever the little orange thing and
that reduces your cooldown every okay so the snare thing is
actually pretty cool if the okay watch him watch apparently
it's invisible to him and then it grabs him and then you can
dash to it too but you only have a couple of seconds so like
i do this And then, don't worry, he's going to go over
there.
And, okay, I put it on the wrong side.
And then, boom!
So, it's an invisible mine.
I don't know what the range is for the dash yet.
But, yeah, so, basically, you can hide in a corner.
Or, like, you know, anti-dive.
And you're like, oh, he doesn't.
No, he doesn't.
And it's like, boom!
so that's a little scary if you do like really cool flanks
with this character i feel i'm still trying to remember the
combo the combo was crazy um it was like what was it it was
like okay it was like this okay it was like you can
basically do a combo that kills a tank but i don't remember
but don't We'll do a combo that kills Luna instead and it
was like what it was like it's like this Or was it like But
she you could kill support super fast with a fucking combo
or some shit I don't know if I can do it correctly Like but
I know that if you hit your shots you can do a crazy-ass
combo Yeah, she's DPS Oh my god if I can get it correctly
Okay, never mind.
No, that's fast.
Wait, actually, that was pretty fast.
That was a... I'm fucking up my combo, but that's still
killed there pretty fast, though.
We have...
If I could get it correctly.
If I could get the combo.
Oh my god.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, oh my god, wait, what the fuck?
Wait a minute.
Okay, wait, wait.
That's actually, I was not expecting that.
All right, wait.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay.
Okay, that's a little scary.
Not gonna lie, especially the...
fling up.
Okay, so Eve flings people up, by the way.
Alright, I'll do it without the Eve flings people up.
So if I do...
Oh, yeah, there you go.
I did the combo.
That's...
Is that scary?
Is that a little scary, guys?
I don't know.
There you go.
I did it.
That's the combo.
Yeah, that's... That's one of the combos that you can do.
So it's right click.
You could do that.
Or you could do... Oh, and I could do another.
I can do another click.
Yeah, so anyway, it's basically it's right click E.
There.
Right click E and then hit again.
Like a two second.
Yeah, that's really fast, by the way.
There we go.
And I get a shield, too.
Yeah, and that combo gives you a shield.
I can't wait to get insta killed by...
Alright, let's enable test it on, Luna.
Now that I remember the combo, it's alright.
Right click.
Oh.
Shouldn't have lived.
Yeah, you get a shield, too.
Alright.
There you go.
Yeah, so, goodbye, Luna.
Oh, wait.
Let me try out on a squishier character, too.
If I hit...
You see, if I was an actual DPS player, that would be
scarier.
Like...
I can't wait for it.
Oh my god.
If I was an actual DPS player, it'd be even scarier, guys.
Alright, let's see it.
Yeah, I can't wait for the DPS players to do this to me.
No, no, you're supposed to stall and then be the change.
Yeah, you see the vision, though.
You see the vision, exactly.
You see the vision.
I wonder if I could do, like, a shift on it.
Wait, actually, wait.
I could do, like, a double E, maybe, right?
Oh, wait, yeah, I can.
If I get him my E, too.
But if I do that, he's just dead.
I feel like, yeah.
Anyway, let's make it so...
Let's see Adam.
So what was about Adam?
Adam?
Wait, let's see.
Adam, apparently he can fly now.
Oh, my God.
Be the change you want to be.
Apparently he hovers.
Oh, my God.
And yet Magneto still can't fly.
And it...
Move it.
Woo.
What the fuck?
He can fucking fly.
Oh, my God.
They finally, he's finally the perfect human being.
I've seen enough and saw the nerf Adam again.
He decided super Adam.
Oh, Lord.
He coming.
For those who don't know, there's the cooldown is two
seconds, but it's also recharging the fuel.
I guess his legs got tired from floating.
We go break his legs again.
That's crazy.
Why that's so fucking silly.
Can he respite air?
I assume so.
Yeah.
Yeah, I can.
I can.
I can also hover.
I'm like, I'm coming over.
I have a weighty fly.
Oh, no.
No, not res cop.
No, don't do it.
I actually want to play Adam.
Adam Haines can fight.
Stop complaining.
We hear you.
We get out of that wheelchair.
It's a Christmas miracle.
You can fly now.
Wee!
Mobility in my Adam gameplay.
What is this?
Join us.
It's time.
It's time for your Adam arc chat.
It really is.
like it's so i'm sorry this is so funny to look at we i
wonder if i can i wonder if i can like uh can i reset this
okay no i can't i wonder okay i can i can actually go up and
down with it it's so funny
is there any what other big changes that they do chat other
than those two other than um elsa and Adam.
But honestly, Elsa, I mean, compared to Deadpool, Elsa isn't
like, doesn't have like super not a lot of different things.
Like, she's just, she's apparently a really fun DPS
character, from what I'm told.
Like, guys, she's a very fun hit scat.
I mean, like, this is really fun to do.
I feel that.
Like, this.
Like, that's really fun.
It won't be fun for me, but if you are a hit scat player, um
this will be very fun this will yeah i'm pretty sure this is
instant yeah no this is hit scan guys look it's literally
instant yeah it's like dps player don't worry we hear you we
always hear you um um i feel like i wonder like the dash
like i could Dash anywhere, basically.
Oh, yeah.
My Dash, like, increases my speed, too.
Yeah.
I forgot about that.
Yeah, see, it hits two, by the way.
The right click hits two bots.
Or, like, it splits up.
So it'll target, like, everyone around you.
Since it's AoE.
That is gonna...
I'm gonna be so scared.
I'm gonna...
I don't know the range of it but it didn't go to this spot
so I think you have to be close by for it what is her
ultimate watch this
like I said you can that's her ultimate you can shoot people
while they're trapped in there and also it immobilizes thing
as well so and I can bring her back and shoot it and you're
like oh that's cool the range is not that bad right and then
you're like oh yeah sure
so like you have to be like okay so this one this one i
think you're safe never mind so maybe here if you're here
all right where's the other bot if you're here you're safe
Never mind?
If you're, if you're here, you're safe.
If you're, there you go.
If you're here, you're safe, guys.
So this is the range between, I think, here maybe.
Nope.
Here you go.
If you're there, not there though, not there.
So, so that's the, that's the range.
it follows you it comes back if you press q so look at this
and then you see call back i can call him back so that's the
thing all right storm oh yeah there's new team ups almost
forgot i have like 10 more minutes before we'll show new
team ups too um two gets everything so i think it was like
what was it guys how do i pull them in Oh, there you go.
I can pull people in with my E now.
Yeah, so I can pull people in.
Can you do it in the air?
I'm pretty sure you can.
But, like, why would you be in...
I mean, you can't even want to get your streamer clips, I
guess.
Like, you see... You see an Ultron in the sky?
I'm pretty sure.
Alright, let's see.
Yeah.
Like, you don't have, like, a...
You don't have, like, a...
floating ability when you pull it off like Adam but you
could technically do that yeah oh yeah Reed has a rocket
team up what was his team up they should pop Elsa so she can
make the monster jump what was the other team up uh receives
a removing his and letting him actively enter the inflation
mode wow wow So how do I activate inflation mode?
Is that it?
Is that inflation?
Oh, enlarge.
There we go.
Oh, so like, there it is.
The what?
Yeah, I'm like, the what mode?
Mr. Fantastic.
Keep that in your bedroom.
So basically, I can...
Okay, he can go inflation mode whenever he wants.
Now, they know what they are doing.
All right.
She also has her own team up, but I feel like it's not, you
don't really see it unless you're on the enemy team.
So targets with Deadpool's chatter while slowing.
So yeah, you don't really notice this unless you're that.
So like, they're basically distracted by Deadpool.
Yeah.
Anyway, so there's that, and then...
Oh, yeah, apparently the Fantastic Four broke up.
No!
Yeah.
They no longer have a team up together.
The bed's broken!
No!
Okay.
I was going to go to their tour.
I thought they will have another tour.
Yeah, so...
Yeah, the thing joined...
The thing joined Hulk and Black Panther.
They can't split up, guys.
I can't believe it.
What happened?
All right, the thing.
The thing gains Gamma Gauntlet boosting damage and range of
his Rocky Jab.
Dealing damage with those grants bonus health.
So you have to do it.
But you have to do a team up with.
How far is this?
Wow!
That's a far range.
Okay, that range is far.
oh okay yeah that's the that's the range for that um and
then and then i believe you guys said that suit uh not uh
storm got a change what is her change
what the what is this i know like the shift is i don't know
what her change is exactly storm got five changes yeah she
apparently she got five changes but i'm not sure exactly oh
it's my h oh oh i have lots of hp now wait i noticed it now
yeah yeah i noticed it never mind i see it now yeah she
gains yeah she gains health uh show wolf's new ult charge
all right i'll show you guys i don't play wolf but i'll show
you i'm the best there isn't what i do but what i do all
right uh let me put the cooldown i don't know how it works
wait i have ult already i'm just wasting my ult real fast
and then i'll reset i'll reset group i'll reset him all
right there you go
i mean that's pretty fast 41 percent
i'm not getting i almost have ult now
have up let's go let's go and everybody's playing Groot oh
no he's back you know what if that means less Groot Moon
Knight combo I'm fine with that I'm I'm fine with that no
more Moon Knight Groot combos give me that shit oh I missed
wait a tin lot let me know no more trees down with the trees
in marvel rivals in marvel rivals in game in game in game
because i i had too much air time okay i was too busy
enjoying this like look like see i'm just having air time i
just wanted to see the sky i wanted to be tall for a second
you know i just i just wanted to be tall Night at the hang
time You really blame me?
Obviously he's not like his prime, but he is stronger than
before Oh gosh, I'm gonna go get ready for the show match I
need to remember where it is Where the server is for that Oh
my god, there's so Guys, I have too many servers I'm trying
to find the Marvel Rivals server.
Okay, preview stream.
There we go.
Okay, nobody's here.
That's good.
Nobody's here yet.
But let me set it up real quick.
I gotta...
Let me set it up real quick.
Whoops.
Oh.
There's that giant...
Giant Fuki thing.
I'm not late, too.
Isn't that great?
I'm finally not late.
Not late.
Well, I'm always never the last one.
there so but like i continue my streak guys okay let me see
a key buttons gotta make sure i have my toggle mute on um
marvel rivals preview nobody's day i don't think people they
realize i don't think they realize that um they changed it
to 30 minutes for the uh for the thing instead of the usual
the usual like what because you in the past we had one we
had one hour to look over everything but I think it's
because there's not a lot of big changes other like Elsa
herself is very she's very straightforward I feel like in
general honestly I feel she's very straightforward so like I
don't think there's like much to really show for one hour
compared to like compared to like the previous early access
yeah like yeah she's just like as long as you get
like like and then we have that too like oh my god what wait
there's no way wait okay yeah she's too shot okay yeah yeah
she's not deadpool where you need like a fucking doctorate
to be able to understand what the fuck is going on oh no
adam thing is yeah oh no she's i saw a tweet there like i'm
not batting elsa because she's broken I'm banning her
because she's British.
All right, for those who want to know what her fistfly looks
like, watch this.
Finally!
The perfect human being!
The perfect specimen!
The perfect specimen is here.
No longer shall he be constrained in his wheelchair.
His recovery, it is a Christmas miracle.
He can fly!
He flies now!
Finally, he's been unleashed.
I've seen enough.
Nerf Adam.
I prayed for time like these.
And then I could do this and hover.
And then I can continue my flight.
I think that's always been the main complaint about Adam.
that he literally is like the slowest guy in the entire
roster like everyone has like some form of mobility to go in
and he's just there like like 20 miles behind the team can
you fly yes he can oh wait no he can't no he can't when
you're healed so that means you gotta stop healing there's a
simple solution for that just never heal
guys then you can fly forever i think you can hover okay the
shift is his if you're in shift form you can also but you
can you can heal while you're in shift form though he's dps
now he's ultron even better than ultron yeah when you use
any other when you attack you can fucking air bomb though
you can fly behind them be like fly behind him he's right
behind me isn't he and then get him from the sky right there
all right let me check plus one dive character he could yeah
you could technically just whoops all dive if you think
about it you could just have all dive all right streamer
mode is disabled oh that means i think everyone else is on
streamer mode okay i think everyone's heading over all right
i think it's almost time time adam is finally real all right
let me let me set up yo guru so because i'm on your team now
you're not tp and me off the map right where the uh no i was
just a joke dude for fucking content all right first time
first time sorry well don't say the f word bro if i can
offer you any advice goodness gracious guru yeah come on man
hashtag it's one of my bad so don't change your name so we
have two tim the tab hands on the team and they don't know
which one's you this is actually they might have told me to
change my name already gosh man we have the meta strats are
here they wouldn't have known who's who maybe this is team a
team did you guys see her lord icon by the way her champion
icon oh my god forgot to show you it goes hard it might be
the most aura i've seen on a lord icon i gotta be honest
with you bro yes like that is yes like i that has so much
aura and then the champion one the movement one right is
sick yes wait who's uh who's making the lobby i don't know
bro probably whips
uh let's see oh yeah i'll show you guys the i'll show you
guys the playing her against gail first i think i'll do it
wait where is it all right let's see what her lord akon is
oh wait that's sick you know what i mean everyone will get
all right the lord is pretty sick honestly oh my gosh it
animates too i actually didn't see that for some reason i
knew there was something i forgot oh yeah in the skin but so
i think but i feel like also there here's her skin probably
because it never pops up okay buddy i'm gonna guess i swear
to god i swear to god if i get kind of confused with cloak
and dagger cloak and dagger sue uh oxy and then here's her
highlight intro team in here yes sir and her other one
bloody barrage said that you can keep the the tim name guru
so there's two of me so they don't know who i am oh yeah and
the recolor icy edge oh wait that goes hard i think i like
icy edge more which one's the real two oh that's hard i
think oh actually i like icy edge a lot i like icy edge the
color scheme for that is pretty good um but yeah here's the
oh yeah i almost forgot i guess i guess boga is making it um
okay it's fashionably lay bro okay which join and i'm in
with boga right now it's just me and i'm Can you invite Tim?
Wait, is Moxie on our team now?
Did they swap teams?
I'm going to check.
Oh, I hope so.
So I don't have to play against Hawkeye.
I finally, I'm free from Hawkeye.
I take those.
Two Tim to tap, man.
Is it?
Yeah.
Freedom.
Because yesterday he was on the enemy team.
Finally.
I don't have to play against Hawkeye.
Oh my God.
No more fear.
Oh, thank God.
Yippee.
Originally, Moxie was supposed to be on the enemy team.
I'm so happy Moxie's on our team.
So I don't have to fear the Hawkeye.
I don't.
I'm so happy.
Oh, go playing like that.
no you don't understand you can never peak quarters i you
should have saw this morning oh well what happened in the
morning i wouldn't worry about it oh no moxie are you are
you not locked in oh my god well let's say guru had a spun
on the bow oh i gave it a i gave it a whirl we're missing
we're missing our other support I think it's like I think
like because they change it because usually it's like an
hour remember we would have an hour to test everything out
but this time is 30 minutes here don't keep her join the
lobby all right is too big for one spot we're gonna five
sorry we get five you six I play Adam you guys see his
flight his flight mode that's just crazy yes it is comedy oh
my god but you can't you can't shoot while flying guys go
ahead no i'm not gonna say anything bro i just think the f
word guru you know what just try it again guru right up go
ahead
hey thank you marvin for sponsoring us over here guys we
appreciate you appreciate you And on February 13th,
everything comes out.
Anyone know what time I was thinking about that today?
Anyone know?
Usually it's like...
What's up?
In the morning.
Yeah, it's usually in the morning, right?
Yeah.
I know like...
I don't know, but it's half season.
Isn't it instant for half season?
It's usually there's like a maintenance during full like
newest seasons, but half season is like instant.
I think you're right.
Yeah, so it should be like late night.
like in the ams like midnight or something yeah yeah saying
4 a.m eastern bro yeah oh one yeah so it'd be 1 a.m pst i'll
be there i know like the new seat like if it's like new new
season then it's like they have like a several hours
maintenance mode there's gonna be a downtime yeah it's a two
hour downtime oxy how you got nine ping bro like where are
you at you in the server i'm in server the server's in my in
my basement yeah he yeah his dad works at net ease hello
hello hello
i think i'm gonna play spider-man what do you guys think
yeah i think you should do it yeah
i was gonna i was gonna try and play jeff at some point too
probably because i do you see the duck costume he's got bro
oh that's true oh the lemonade stand is cute by any chance
but once name uh it's just me i'll put it in the general oh
thank you thank you moxie all right nice okay yeah yeah guru
you gotta be a little faster but sorry sir oh it's discord
kind of low guys all right i'll i i don't i don't think my i
don't know my audio team is on today i had a reset real
quick but it's my what's my where's is my audio sound guys
there today sound guy if you are here type in
i forgot to get my sound guy on uh are you guys nervous i
forgot to get my sound guy here uh like on deck no on call i
think it is his first time bro i'm not nervous if it was i'm
gonna play adam are we playing casual or are we sweating
this time because last time i think my computer well we'll
see how it goes we'll see it's usually that's what early
access is we'll see how the enemy team plays so i'm playing
adam it's not casual i'm playing adam i already got paid
though so
yo can someone go sue so i can try that new team up was
strange let's go max i'm on it got that on a little quick
moss all right let's go all right who's playing I'll fly
over with you guys Got any flankers we got I'm playing for
that in here.
We got Tim flanking.
All right, I'll fly with you I fly with you and I have soul
bottom.
You got me to flank is strange.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you flank Wait, oh wait, yeah, which is which which is
which?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
We have to get a screenshot together.
We look so good.
We're gonna They're gonna throw the enemy team off so you
don't know which ones.
Yeah, they don't know which one.
They're like, kill Tim.
Which Tim?
Tim's one shot.
Tim one and Tim two.
I'm Tim one, by the way.
Yeah, who is Tim Prime?
All right, how are we going to flank Tim?
All right, Jay, don't choke this, bro.
All right, this is my life depends on this.
Yeah, that's Jeff.
Oh, they're using that.
They're doing thing and hook.
Oh.
I'm scared.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I'm flying over.
Oh, see it's easy.
Oh my god.
I'm so bad.
No.
No, it's okay.
Oh my gosh, the damage is crazy though.
Um.
We're so healthy.
Pin roll play.
Oh, you can shoot the trap before you even...
I saw it.
Oh, I have so bad, unfortunately.
Yeah, there's too much damage.
This Thing Hulk is terrifying.
I can't even lie to you.
Is Thing Hulk like the new tank lineup?
Wait, wait.
I mean, they got the Gamma team up now.
Does that mean we're getting our own Thing Hulk?
Maybe about after.
After Strange Alture.
Yeah, after Strange Alt.
That pull is so cheeky.
Oh, wait.
There is a hook behind us.
There's still a Hulk behind us.
All right, Malaya, that's on you.
Wait, Hulk behind us, I think, right?
I'm in the trap.
Is there a Hulk behind us?
I couldn't, I don't know.
I'm scared.
You're not scared.
I'm floating.
Chad, tell Puffer that I said that alt was ass.
Go tell him I said that.
There's a gap top.
Oh, it's so Adam.
Get him.
I see why they asked you to be.
here wow jay can we alt together i want to see if you could
push my all into there into them oh test it oh oh yeah wait
is that oh wait that's oh yeah we got some early tech combo
i haven't tested it yet that's what early access is for yeah
over on the point that's what you're gonna do i'm gonna fly
away i'm flying away Don't worry.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
I can't I can't come over.
I can fly and all oh huge huge rest huge fly rest Oh, it's
okay.
I can I can also rest.
Oh my god.
You want to try it?
I'm doing it?
Yes, please.
Oh my god.
Oh, I might I might have missed.
Oh, no, no, no, no, you just go right through it You
absolutely might have not worked.
No, no, no, no, no, you just fly right.
It's fine.
Hold on.
I need to.
Oh, God.
It's buffer
All of you!
That old is terrifying!
Apparently he has 500 HP, so you technically...
You could technically kill him.
Oh, my goodness, bro.
That thing owns...
That is scary.
Can you shoot it when you're getting charged?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can.
Not when you're in it, but your teammates can.
I'm really stunned.
I mean, why can't...
Moxie, let's relax here, bro.
I'm just saying.
I got Invisal.
I'm holding forward.
Oh, no, I'm not.
Oh, okay.
Where's the Orel?
Where is it, Moxie?
Come on.
Where's the Orel?
Oh, I got you.
I got you right here.
You can't shoot the little...
Oh.
The trap.
You cannot?
Right here.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Nice up, nice up, nice up.
Yeah, these guys have no idea what it is.
Oh my god, they're so clean.
Look at that, triple here.
Let's go mox.
T9.
Oh shit, you're right, don't worry, I'm flying over.
Oh, oh, wait.
Oh, they're just trying to see that.
My dad.
I'm dead.
They won't know.
again nice in the sky oh beautiful res beautiful okay i
think i think the fly is pretty broken not gonna lie where'd
they go chat i should be the rest where'd they just right
there yeah but he's not flying for it he's not flying for it
oh never mind i'm scared i'm scared i'm scared i'm not
afraid anymore Oh, no.
Don't be scared.
We can win this.
It's possible.
It's win.
Oh, I don't think so anymore.
Dude, if that thing pulled me from the other side of the
vehicle, are you scrolling?
I don't think it's weird.
It was on the opposite side.
I'm coming.
It's okay.
We wanted to play more of this map because we love this map.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This map was just so fun.
Yes.
That ult is unbelievable, bro.
Yeah, the range is crazy for it.
I was testing it out earlier.
Oh, that's you.
You guys see that Hulk above us?
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't know what's going on.
Oh, yeah.
I got the Hulk.
I see the Hulk.
He's right behind us.
He flew towards him.
Where's Moxie?
Oh, God.
He's so low.
I'm here.
hey hey guys um i got juggled behind us there you go oh i
got some healing yep maybe oh oh he's still there respect
the 1v1 wait wait don't respect that i need any medical
assistance oh right you won the 1v1 the range on the e is
crazy oh wow that's a lot of damage ult them thank you in
your all yeah like this oh pulling back pulling back yeah
yeah oh that's sick good combo guys a huge oh is coming from
the thing right now just just watch this i'm scared never
mind i'm floating away yeah i got old nice beautiful oh
adam's low oh never mind he died Don't believe this guy?
He's shooting me.
I got you.
You just solo all...
It was worth it.
I didn't serve my dominance, okay?
He's not even flying when he does it.
I got you, I got you!
Oh, not that though.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
It's okay.
Oh my god!
Rez!
What is happening?
Oh shit!
All right, that's all the rest I could do.
I got you 30 seconds.
Insane heals.
I have the whole physics.
Oh my gosh, I'm alive.
Um
I'm referring to the Hulk right now.
Oh my god.
I'm coming back.
Don't worry about the Hulk I'm dead He buffered just
right-clicking me dude.
Oh, I guess I leave Bro your little fly.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
That's a lot of damage.
Oh dear.
The best I can do is give you a soul bond i have no more
snaps you almost got your alts again i'll wait for you bro
we could try and mean that again oh shoot why does this
punish yeah no more soul bond uh i don't think i just got it
i just got it i just got it oh my god i got the lead it's so
fast Yeah.
I'm, I'm.
Oh, what happened?
What happened?
You got it?
How many of you got it?
Don't worry about it.
Oh, I see what you're doing.
Let the game continue.
Good shit.
Yeah, yeah.
We wanted to see the duck, right?
I like it.
Yeah, yeah.
Good play.
Wait, TP out for the new duck scam.
I like it.
Anyone that TP.
Oh, we're in the TP?
TP right now?
All right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it's a long walk there.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, Punisher got us buff, right?
Oh my god.
They had the read.
Wait, Punisher one, Punisher one.
I'm still bonding us in.
Get in there.
I'm scared now.
Oh my god.
It's going off the map.
Oh, no, it's not.
It's okay.
Oh, it's no longer okay.
Oh, thank you.
I'm snapping.
I'm getting smacked around.
I'm getting smacked.
I'm snapping.
I don't have snaps no more.
I have two guys.
Two guys back here.
Big!
Don't worry.
Nice, nice, nice.
Point again, point again.
I'm flying in to get you guys in.
There is a atom at the very top.
How much health does puffer have?
Yeah, right.
We have an atom in the middle of our...
Yeah, no, he's left.
I know how to handle this.
Just don't need to look at it.
Wait, I'm getting shot at by something.
It's happening.
I'm just bouncing.
goodbye i fly away
goodbye right oh shit wow wow that are all that is i think
i'm going off the map okay oh you're fine you're fine i
think i'm going off the map oh my god the up just left no
you're doing circles you're doing circles that's why you
rank one dude oh
I died, guys.
It's okay.
We can all reset right here.
And Thing Hulk is actually insane.
Is it?
Yeah, it's crazy, yeah.
The range for the Thing and the Hulk.
We gotta get in there.
I'm scared too.
I don't know if it's gonna work, though.
Oh, that's true, that's true, that's smart.
Although, it's gonna be hard to do that.
Yeah, I'm gonna try here, though.
And whatever.
Buffalo, Buffalo.
I think they have a res, don't they?
Beautiful Jeff.
Yeah, there it is.
The res is on the board.
He's dead.
Oh my god.
I still find it.
No, I can't live.
No.
It res.
Oh, come on.
Nice.
Good job.
We can push that.
I think, yeah, that's totally doable.
Every time I fly, the Hulk just grabs me from the skies
traumatizing.
So who said they're going Hulk and thing?
All right, wait.
No, we're not getting the gamma going?
Oh.
No, there's a cool there.
All right, guys, how's the volume?
Guys, sound team is...
not alive both tim's on the front line audio audio team is
not alive today so is discord good or should i raise it up
volume is good oh smash all right good it comes j is quiet
yeah audio team is not uh uh what's the word it's not online
today jay's a little quiet okay i'll up jay anyone want to
go in for a little dip right here a little bit you got a
lemonade stand a little little dip oh oh that's cute does
anyone else want to try out adam he's pretty fun with the
fly i'll be down to try him next game i think jay's trying
to get that bro dude this character is so fun bro that that
ultimate took me from another side of the car like i was on
that other side of the car to get that oh no no clip today
it's actually pretty wide I'm going out the right door.
Oh, they have Angela.
They have Angela.
Careful.
That was really smart.
Lie.
Oh, you're...
Don't worry, I'm so bad.
I'm so bad.
Oh, not for you though.
Angela?
Oh, Lord.
Oh.
Oh, goodbye.
You guys are... Yeah, yeah, we are.
They're gone.
Don't worry, the healers are still alive.
Yo, this might be the worst composition to run Hulk Femin 2.
Let's get him.
I believe.
This might be a really bad heal cop, too.
No, I don't know.
It's perfect.
Oh, wait.
Oh, straight slow, straight slow.
Make it happen.
Thank you so much.
No.
Oh, I got so bad.
I'm no so bad.
Flying away.
Oh, wow.
Oh, yeah, we're so dead.
Holy, that was damage.
But that was a few ults.
They're going to have a...
Oh, Moxie's got Invis?
What do you got, Mox?
Invis, Invis, invis, in...
Oh, no!
Tim, did you get...
Which Tim got him?
Amazing ult.
Yeah, watch out for...
Watch out for Dr. Change ult.
That one?
Oh, what?
He's got me!
What is going on?
I did this turn around for a second.
to us why couldn't tim do that yeah i literally just got
kidnapped by the creature and then altered by straight like
oh my god can i get in this now can i get in this okay it's
mox yeah it's actually it's insane trust trust trust
trusting you okay i'll pull them back i'll pull them back
here or i can try to send some off the map i'm flying away
but i'm dead no yeah bring it back i could try to knock them
off the map What the?
Oh, there's Adam.
Oh, that's SOMG going off the map.
Yeah, no, no res, no res.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Another ult?
That seems crazy.
That is a lot of ult.
I'm dead here.
This guy didn't play enough Punisher today?
He is the Punisher guy.
He has to play Punisher.
Wait, strange is one.
Yeah, strange little change little.
Yeah, yeah, nice.
Huge.
Oh, no, not the gripper.
Wait, who's portaling?
Is that our portal?
I have a portal.
Don't let him touch me.
They're gonna try to- Wait, wait.
Angela, they're gonna touch you.
They're gonna touch you.
Yeah, I'm putting a chop right here.
I like that.
All right, I might swap off.
I'm hearing a Hulk.
Oh, shit.
Stop TP.
That's not just- That's not just any Hulk.
Nice!
That's the Tim Hulk.
Are you going to be okay, Moxie?
They're all chasing you right now.
I save you.
I only got...
I can only get one person, though.
Yeah, that's my bad.
I don't have any more heals, though.
I could die.
Okay.
I'm swapping.
What goes well with...
Invis.
They nerfed at Loki, right?
They nerfed the bullets.
Could that be...
Oh, maybe Cloak for the counter of Elsa?
Maybe.
Oh, Tim?
What are you doing?
Why are you portaling me off the map?
Why are you doing?
I had to.
That's why we were down a player the whole time.
Yeah, that makes sense, actually.
Oh, wait, that's him!
That's him!
It's good, it's good.
Oh, my God.
Did you get anyone?
No, I tried to bring it back.
Wow, well, here.
I hope you guys will be okay.
Okay, I'm lying to me.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm boker.
I am so fucked up right now back here.
I'm okay.
Yeah.
How about that, Puffer?
Bro, do you see how fast Adam's flying in the air right
here?
Look at me.
Don't worry about it, bro.
I love Puffer.
Everything's fine.
It's all good, man.
Keep going.
I'll just hear for the vibes, guys.
Nice, Moxie.
Good 1v1, bro.
I'm here, I'm here.
Let's go.
I'm running, I'm low.
Go, go fight him.
I'm here, I'm right here.
All right.
Yeah, we believe in you.
Oh, they're scared.
Yeah, I still got you.
What is going on here?
I'm going in, I guess.
Good action.
Massive heals.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wow.
You guys are fine.
Oh, my God.
You live.
You love.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
You're so healthy.
Nice.
See, he's so healthy.
A moxie pocket.
Guys, are we pushing the crow defending?
I'm confused.
That's how we play.
Yeah.
Oh, that crow.
I can't kill him.
This guy's unkillable.
I've grabbed him three times.
I got you.
What was that?
He's unkillable.
Oh, there's a dust.
Oh, it's a dust.
It's a body.
Yeah.
Oh, Tim, be careful.
He's portaling.
Tim, be careful.
They're all supporting the battle of the mines.
Yeah, whose portal is gonna hit?
Took you a really long time.
Oh.
What's going on there?
I have a lot of first.
There's a paper angle.
That's a few people I think off the map.
Oh!
Oh, did you do it?
Wait, I just won?
No, I don't see anybody right now.
Wait, I see the res.
Guys, the res.
Huge.
Oh, nice.
Nice up.
Thank you.
There's someone over here.
Yeah, they are not winning.
Oh, the items up top.
Nice, good stuff.
Nice, guys.
Good round.
GG's.
See, we don't need a Punisher, guys.
True, bro.
That literally...
But that guy farmed all so fast.
Every fight, it felt like...
Wait, so which Tim had the 25 finals?
It was Guru, right?
Mm-hmm.
No.
No, just checking.
That was this Tim.
Good shit, Goo.
You gotta step it up, Tim.
Okay, dude.
Six finals is...
That's really...
How is Moxie stealing my MVP?
Oh, wait, how do I have more finals than the other team?
You're right, you're right, you're right.
It's because you, it's because you soaked up all that damage
in my ult.
Good job.
You probably, literally.
That's not me for the record.
That's Guru.
Actually, wait.
Yeah, yeah.
That funny joke.
You can play it then.
You can play it.
No, I'll play it.
Yeah, you can play it, man.
Uh, no, I'll play.
I want me.
Shockborn.
You're so stupid.
I can do whatever.
Who wants to do what?
Yeah, I'll be the shy.
Do we need another tank?
I'm flying, bro.
It's so fun.
It's really fun.
I'm glad to add that up.
I'm just playing for the vibes today.
You wanna play Elsa?
I can play.
I can do her later.
I can play her later.
You're gonna do what?
Yeah.
It's not gonna go wild, but I mean, I can play her.
I forgot, guys.
i forgot to equip the duck skin i went i forgot to get the
cosmetic i'm not afraid we have no tank though right now i'm
defunct andy i can go tank i'm defunct andy is this like a
shiny charizard bro no this is wait yeah i'll get the group
going no group what happens if i all into your grudel oh
wait wait do you take them out do we breaks the game maybe
oh oh they're here bro do you see how they want to copy me
so bad this is ridiculous everyone wants to be you it's
ridiculous i don't want to alarm you guys but uh adam
warlock on the flank oh i'm hit oh what is happening are you
still flanking i yeah welcome back
all right on the only jeffiers thank you so much amazing
amazing heels i already have a lot here where's my adam are
you still fighting are you there's elsa coming up here oh my
god i can go thor i don't know who our adam is oh wait wait
no we got this we got this
That's beautiful.
That's absolutely.
It's gonna be huge.
It's gonna be so huge.
I got no one No, we lost Jake All right I'm scared.
I made a mistake.
He should be scared.
Oh my goodness.
Jay, is that is the is bogers still behind us?
Oh, yeah, he's right here.
Yeah No more He's flying away That's okay, we got him we got
Wait, can we even touch?
I don't think we can.
I got him!
He was one.
He was one HP.
That was a good angle to use it though.
That was, that's smart.
Guys, I'm being insulted.
Goodbye.
Yo, Moxie, I'm gonna try and get my alt bro.
Let's try to do ours together and just see what happens.
Okay, okay.
I will call it up.
There is a Thor to our left.
Oh, they have Thor old, by the way.
Oh, that is scary.
Oh, we don't have anything for that.
Um, who are the third-point team, I think?
Yo, Jeff, did you not throw my game on Elsa?
How are you Owing for?
Because he lost two 1v1s with Bougar.
Do you not see...
I saw you 1v1 in Bougar, bro, and you lost.
Wait, wait, wait.
It's like dragon balls you in the back line Here I'm linking
us let's go Oh dear Oh dear Wow Whoa whoa whoa That's huge
That's huge That huge is huge That is huge Where are you
Jeff?
Where are you Jeff?
Well Okay you oh shit Okay hi I'm in it now Although Is this
good I got you Tim You gotta hit this you gotta hit this Tim
We're turning around.
Oh, why did you leave me here?
We're huge.
We're huge, donkeys.
I'm scared.
I'm flying.
I'm coming.
Stop the mall.
Oh, my goodness.
Nice.
Good job, team.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, we're here.
We're good.
Everything's okay.
Moxie, you playing Fortnite over here, bro?
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm first time in this.
I'm really.
What the fuck is this?
How many hours of crew do you have?
I don't know how to play.
This is my first hour.
I thought I'd do it.
you guys oh this is a special moment i'm scared hey guys can
i give him my alt please i thought it was really oh my god i
linked oh you're okay what just happened uh the group wall
destroyed the all he no it's because it hit i i ulted and
then i walled myself off oh my god thank you so much thank
you so much thank you cheers mate they have a lever we can
win oh my god they do Go on, go on, gifted us.
He got Dift, he got Dift, I understand.
It happens.
Oh.
We're okay, we're okay.
Her trap is so good.
Wow.
I'm not right clicking at all, by the way.
Wait, there's a, there's an Adam right behind us, thank you.
I can rise you guys.
Wait, Jay, what if you win him?
Oh, I have rise, I'm hiding right now.
Die on point.
I don't want to lose again.
Yeah, smart, smart, smart, just hide there.
Die on point, he has Riz.
He died, she died, she died?
oh i think this is it i think this is time this is the
biggest rest of your life i pulled them out of the alt but i
couldn't kill them unfortunately where are you jeffers where
are you jeff where are you on the fly i don't see you i got
two i got two get over here all right there you go oh nice
beautiful yeah oh oh oh
That's a little awkward.
Why didn't he fly up?
Guys, I'm gonna go in for uh for Groot ult right here right
here.
Okay.
Two.
It's happening.
Oh!
Okay.
It's okay.
I got two.
Two.
I mean they got me.
We got killed.
Nice.
Thank you.
That's good.
No, I have Link.
I have Link and we can fly.
Let's get it.
I don't feel so good.
I don't, I don't know any.
Oh, he's coming for me.
He's coming for me.
Oh, dear.
That's, uh, I'm dead.
That was, that was all targeted.
I died.
Oh, we lost.
It's okay.
It's still winnable.
Reportedly.
He's pulling off a God TP.
Hang on.
I see it happening in real time.
I don't know what I was waiting for.
I'll be on it.
Yeah, I was going to say.
It's not getting more crafty than you think it was.
It's okay.
I'm sort of stuck here.
I got you.
Come on.
I got you with the heels.
Oh.
Um, hello.
He was talking about me.
Boom.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
You have a res.
Oh, I thought there was two people dead.
The res.
GG.
All right.
I'm throwing.
Yeah, GG.
Report R.
Adam.
Already did.
Are you, are you thinking that our, that was not good?
Oh, they win.
They beat.
Oh, guys.
I think we should have just punched up, boy.
Guys, the guys, guys, guys.
Wait, you said your Adam's throwing.
Wait a minute.
Wait, I have three.
I have three.
I'm sending it in our backline, so good luck, guys.
Right here in our bin.
Oh, and then.
Oh, this is not looking good.
That's not, that's a little awkward.
I backcapped.
Nice.
Yeah, that was the plan.
Check this.
Ow, ow.
What is happening?
They capped back.
Thank you.
Oh, nice.
That guy got the leading.
Nice aim.
Yo, I have my all.
It could high key win this, bro.
Yes.
Yeah.
I wish Tim was just cracked.
I'm Tim.
Tim one and Tim two.
Thank you.
Oh, that makes sense.
What 11 and four?
I got plenty of room here.
Oh, making,
making, making.
No more bubbles.
Oh, oh, my God.
Our strange got a huge ult.
I don't know.
He got a huge one.
Guys, I think I'm bringing it back.
Oh, my God.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's far.
Oh, that's huge.
Oh, um, um, I hoped.
I hoped, I hoped.
That's actually crazy.
We're using this for my mental reasons from msm i got you
guys yeah that's good that's good you guys too you rest too
you wear the wolverine get told fast oh they're born again
nice nice nice nice
um you're so oh nice good job i just got slammed oh my god
that's no way no
come on
the all had like I don't know how many bro I am doing an ad
this is hammered it's just walking guys I'm literally doing
that don't stop oh my god bro what was that go to the course
I have no idea bro that actually sounds so fun to have
friends like that yes I'm like that yeah here we go oh my
god bro what's going on over there too I just had three
buddies including Cloaksey who is a streamer hey guys that
just walked into my house in my room so hello it's marble
bro I love marble for free can't say that but yeah that is
please bro am I tanking am I tanking this I'm tanking this
let us let us you
you said it free too you've certainly come a long way since
the enclave created you adam
okay boxy can come down a little bit and then
okay and then overall wait wait maybe i go all right let me
know if it's better i'm coming i'm coming sorry okay hello
hello hello hello I thought we had a strange, my bad.
I can go.
You go.
Was that a team up?
Was that going to be a team up?
Yeah, dude.
Well, we could have done, I could have done Sue if you
wanted to stray in chat here.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's so cool.
It's okay.
Jeff is cool, too.
There's on the screen right now.
Oh, my God.
I just blew up.
Oh.
Oh, it's okay.
It's we're even.
We're even.
I'm afraid.
We're technically even.
Oh.
There's a...
Overreed right behind us.
Oh, no
Everything is fine.
Thank you.
Thank you dolphin.
Oh We he's almost done.
It's almost done.
It's insane brother.
Wow.
Okay.
It is breakable
Stop up Oh, I'm so low.
I have no idea what I'm doing on this right here.
Do you strange and I'll shoot.
Yeah, I'm coming.
I'm going somewhere Okay.
I don't know how to play this character.
Do you know how to play Strange or do you want to sue?
I can play a thing if you want.
Let me know.
I'll strike.
Check out.
Um, Thor is low.
Okay, I'm gonna play anything but he can't kill me anymore.
I'm going in.
Okay.
Oh, they're flying away.
We- everyone's running away.
Uh, there's a Thor behind us.
Um, pick me up, please.
Pick me up.
Please pick me up.
Oh shit.
It's too late.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my God.
At least Belgrade's dead.
That's all that matters.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
We are born again.
I got you.
Oh, my God.
Born again.
I'm healing you.
Oh, nice res, nice res.
Oh, thank you so much.
What about healing me though?
Oh, I'm back.
Okay.
I'm running, bro.
I have a Thor on me.
Oh, thank you.
Wow.
okay believe it or not I think I can't wait I believe I
believe listen we're gonna be in flow state here now and I
don't think we're gonna lose a fight from this point on oh
there's someone top right I left sorry I agree there's a
Wolverine above us he's a non-factor don't even worry about
him he's that oh good Bye.
Thank you so much.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, is it huge?
It's huge.
I can't heal right now.
Huge.
Good stuff team.
Nice, nice.
Are you porting?
No portal?
Nice guys.
Hey, bad guy here.
Don't worry.
You're planning on walking back.
Red team?
Red team there?
Wait, Tim, you should send your ult through this thing like
he did last time.
yeah if i don't die or if he doesn't die you can there you
go hopefully that helps you all this oh god oh they're
coming over they're coming over i'm getting solo altered oh
no that was such a good oh um none of them actually i want
to tp back to you guys wait wait wait wait wait Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
What happened to your other?
I'm so confused.
Yeah, I'm so confused.
I didn't, uh.
Oh, wait, someone touched it Cause I can almost, uh.
Oh no!
I'm pointing if you die, dying point.
Okay, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have all two.
Where's my board again?
Where's the board again?
Oh, there it is!
Oh my god, it's major.
Nice.
Wow, tickers fast.
The Thor's on me.
There we go.
That was crazy.
You cannot rush it.
I saw that bogey running at you.
I saw the fear in your eyes.
I saw.
The Wolverine was in my face too.
Yeah, scared a little bit.
what is that oh that's a you can fly away you can fly away
from him
oh my god they're going full flanker mode yeah what the heck
oh man down they killed it they killed my old oh my god they
focused fire so you can run it kind of quick huh yeah so it
is it's possible to survive Huge.
I'm just hitting them with the old school stuff, bro.
You know what I mean?
Ooh, the fly up.
That old school altar out of the corner.
The retro.
Yeah, old strats become new strats.
They put, no, they're not purling.
They have to go through the door.
I have an old one.
They push in.
I have an invisible.
Oh, they're coming.
I'll match late.
I'll match.
They're coming.
Oh, okay.
All right.
I'm doing that to live.
Oh, my God.
Big eat.
I have three.
I send them all the way back and I'm gonna die for it.
This guy's chasing me, bro.
Why are you chasing me?
Oh my god, there's so many people coming over.
They're coming over now.
I'm flying away.
Fly away.
We need your res.
Why am I 1 HP?
Oh my gosh.
Was that just Elsa doing that damage to me?
Wow.
I'm moving the cart guys.
Adam's on cart.
Oh.
Nice.
Not anymore.
Oh, okay.
Yo, he's one.
He's overheating.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wait, did I eat you guys while you were in that ult?
You ate at the end of it, yeah.
Oh, shit.
Oh, yeah.
Six.
I saved you guys.
I'm fucking dead.
I'm heckin' dead.
Hmm.
Oh, so you can counter it with a Jeffy.
That's cool.
Sorry, guys.
First time.
Do what I say, not what I do.
Very interesting.
Got you, Moxie.
Thank you.
just die die tied together i can i can get the res here i
have my move hey guys there's a black panther right here i
don't know if you guys care oh my god there's a sword to our
right corner are you telling me to die well i don't need to
tell you to die damn i need assistance if possible thank you
i think you guys are just gonna oh shit i got black
GG.
Oh, we cracked roll.
Oh my gosh.
We should start a team.
Yo, you guys want to?
Oh my gosh.
We should get signed.
Sentinels.
That's me.
Complexity or something?
I don't know if I'm getting good at Jeffolds or it's because
I'm not fighting against pros.
I'm not like against a full pro team.
I thought I ate my own Elsa.
My own Elsa's all.
And I was like, oops.
But in the end, I saved my team.
Look at that.
I did a game remove.
What, what, what, what?
You're Elsa.
I'm Elsa.
I don't.
Okay.
Wait, Moxie, you never get to try out the new characters.
No, I'll play it after.
i'm not actually you play first half i'll play second half
okay yeah yeah what should i do maybe you tank all i got him
all right allora all right let's do this that's crazy that
you can stop you can stop the you can stop it with the uh
with the fucking Jeff up it has like three procs or
something or two procs support pool isn't how much were you
guys using the flight jet uh not um every so often oh that's
true his bar uh recharge is very slow but it's actually
really fun all right yeah support pool for the yeah I'm
expecting some J reses J level reses I'll see what I can do
I got you I don't even remember how to play support pool.
I appreciate the compliment.
I have 10 minutes on this character.
I'm gonna give it my all.
I believe.
What is this?
I just got squirrel grilled.
Oh yeah, they buffed there, didn't they?
I snapped my finger and you died at the same time.
Like, I actually...
Oh, there are gambits!
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no.
Wait, it's okay if they are not going Gambit Loki.
Yo, you got Red?
This is crazy.
Wait, wait, wait.
Did you say Gambit Loki?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
They're just Gambit.
Just Gambit.
It's just Gambit.
I'm going to Gambit Loki.
I got a Loki on me.
Oh, bro.
You want to...
Yeah, and I can...
You can run Cloak with it, too.
You know, I can run Cloak.
I can run Gambit if you want to run Loki, Gambit, bro.
I can run Gambit.
So what's the go like?
No, no, no, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, sure, sure.
Yeah, let's just put Moxie on Hawkeye too while we're at.
Yeah, yeah, Moxie on Hawkeye.
I can't go Loki, but I can do Gambit if you want.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I'll do, I'll swap with you.
Yeah, we can lock in.
Yeah, yeah, let's lock in.
Let's lock in here.
Oh, wow.
Well, in our defense, they pick Gambit first.
Yeah, yeah, that's true.
That's true.
We're only counting Gambiting.
And we want to know.
like how it's okay we can destroy this and to be fair look
they did nerf loki oh geez oh wow wait they went rogue oh my
god oh huge oh my god huge reds huge red all right we'll use
your gamble first i got mine here here get in front of me
get in front of me oh huge wait get her all right and then i
have the next oh wait actually we don't need it there we go
i just gotta yo get this guy off squirrel girl wait i need
help i need yours right now he's one he's one he's one do
you guys feel your senses different on this one not really
do you have your like did you do the mouse uh was it raw
input i don't know i feel like every time we do this it's
different Oh, I didn't do come.
I don't have confirmation.
Shit.
It's okay.
I have cabin never falls Oh, they're so far Okay, it feels
like we're folding right now.
Oh, they're all in there.
They're all in there.
Oh my god.
Nice Wait, I got him.
I got him.
It was all planned huge.
Oh, no, it wasn't that was a good That was a good early
gambit.
It was just lounging.
It was huge Yeah,
that was messed up It was one of Tim's ideas.
Yeah, true.
I'll take credit.
Other Tim.
Yeah.
Credit is...
Who's which Tim?
I'm holding this.
I'm also holding this.
Yep.
Right here.
Three.
Oh, no.
Man down, man down.
Oh, it's all of them!
Oh, shit, that's...
I sold on it.
W.
I can't hit him.
It's okay.
We should be able to...
You can sort of tell the, they did nerf the healing a little
bit.
I like your little spot up there, Squirrel Girl.
That's really nice.
Thank you.
Help me, Tim.
You almost have another gambit up.
Oh, I think they destroyed it.
Your friends are where?
Yeah, where did your friends go?
I almost if you live if you live I have my own almost I'm
gonna fly off the map.
Oh, maybe not.
Oh Um Tim that um
Tim you might need to be a little higher
Okay, I'm gonna see any touch any touch because I can use my
old here.
Here here.
I'm holding you guys And I'll have cabin never folds again
Oh, no can i can see you guys on our side wait copy tim and
then this was a oh my god you're so right we're still trying
to say i'm a genius i couldn't fight i couldn't fight him i
i want v6 hang on hang on i got this guys you got this me i
think that went really well i'm not an adam player no admit
it at one point i flew head first into the squirrels
I'm trying to find the confirmation Where the fuck is the Oh
there you go, double confirmation There you go, that fucked
with me whenever Alright, Doki, it is your turn Alright,
you're on Adam duty I am Loki What should I do?
Gambit, Gambit, Gambit, Gambit No, Adam, sorry You're on
Loki duty Oh, do you still want to do Loki in this?
Or do you want to do double res?
Gambit, oh with me, oh with me, oh with me Oh I don't Emo,
Emo, Emo with me, sorry, sorry Oh, my bad, my bad Oh T, T,
oh, I hit Oh, they're getting a divorce It's so sad Oh!
I didn't realize there was a bridal carry Imagine if you
could run around with me in your arms Can you do that?
Maybe they could add it to Times Square Oh
Thank you, Nyxta.
Oh.
Oh, storm low.
I'm being shot.
You're in Zimbabwe.
No, you can see me.
I know you can.
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, dear.
Is everything okay?
Wait, he's low.
Bro, glow.
Oh, he's getting here.
Bro, I'm shooting, bro.
I started blasting.
Rogue's so low.
She's getting healed.
Rogue doesn't die.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, big.
Big huge, huge.
Oh, they messed up.
They messed up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We could go with my own here.
I'm burning.
I'm burning it.
Oh, I am dead here, though.
Can I even...
Can I alt that, I wonder?
Oh, huge.
another one oh nice that's nice sim i'm out here there i got
him i got one what is going on i i i don't know no no no oh
no right there oh no someone look at gail's movement i can't
hit this guy wait i'm watching your pov right get up there
yo i can't hit that
Unfortunately, I actually saw that happen.
Bro, he is the fastest dude in the world.
That's what speed does.
You mean hit AIM Labs, chat?
AIM Labs is not going to help that!
Wait, they're running triple support.
Did you guys notice that?
I mean, we ran triple support, too.
Yeah, to be fair, they're counting.
It's when the other team does it.
That's what it matters.
That was okay.
No, they did it first.
That's true.
They did it first.
first oh that's that's that's that's that's look she has she
is so she is so strong i'm scared me too well let's just say
that we feel bad because we won the last that's true that's
true we gave them a freebie i just came out on spider-man
thinking you didn't have touch don't worry don't Horribly.
Oh.
I can't win them all, guys.
We're just, we were sad bagging on purpose.
We're like, we're giving them a plus one, you know?
You know, guys, we were just letting them have that chat.
They needed this win.
It would be really rude, you know?
we just wanted to have a fun time chat we wanted to have a
fun time to win to win so it would be like equal
exactly yeah exactly see we're so humble so humble i don't
know i won't play in this morale just drop what happened
everybody got so quiet tim just got one guide and we saw it
happen live
What's the one guy?
All right, they're making me lock in, bro.
I don't want to have those.
They're making me lock in.
I mean, wait, which Tim asked for palace?
He did.
That's guru.
Dude, stop doing that.
Because if we lose on Tim's map, then Tim might have to go
to AIM Labs.
No, no, no.
That was guru.
I am Dr. Strange right now.
Yeah, I'm Elsa.
Yeah, but I didn't type anything.
That's you.
How do we know that?
Bro, what are you doing?
What are you?
This is me.
See?
Wait, that's Guru?
Yeah, is that Guru?
Guru said go to the pal.
No, he said go to the pal.
I don't know why you're doing this.
There is fine proof.
I'm down to play the old map.
It's not a big team.
This is weird.
Wait, why are we playing this map again?
Are we rematching?
I guess so.
Yeah.
Now that we're serious for real, we're locked in now.
Someone's on Hawkeye.
Moxie, get on Hawkeye now.
I'm on.
I'm going to zoom in back to spawn.
Yeah, Moxie, show them.
Show them you're a better Hawkeye.
Oh, I'm not a better Hawkeye than him.
Oh, it's not Gail.
Never mind.
I'm fine.
Oh, shit.
See, you're a better Hawkeye.
shit it is characters crazy damn wait guru is locking in for
real on strange guru why couldn't I do that when I played um
guys I am on string well guru you're so good at string you
got like four kills thank you I played it
professionally I'm coming I'm coming oh my god I'm dead oh I
pulled some back oh i'm backing up what's happening i don't
know but i'm backing up anything i have this disappear we
can push him up i pulled them all i'm i got puffer no no i
think that's good i got puffers yeah oh my bad nice shot
guru Hey, keep it up on strange man.
You're popping off The best is strange Yo, everyone's on
spider?
Good chance dude.
I see you Yeah, I see you spider man.
You're doing great too It doesn't show on the scoreboard,
bro Yeah, they see my stats.
They don't see my story though That you're creating that
let's have those kills They see my stats.
They don't see my story.
Wow Wait, wait, wait.
See nine?
See nine Oh, we're good.
Subtle touch Hey, one kill, I made it count.
Yeah, yeah, the kill that counts.
I'll roll the map, I think.
Nice, dude.
Okay, nice.
They're so healthy.
Oh?
Oh, I got this.
I got this.
All right.
Guru's TPing them right now?
Do you, should I cancel it?
Should I cancel it or no?
I'm trying it.
Hang on.
Oh.
I don't know if I got them.
Wait, what did you do?
I didn't get them for everybody.
Oh, wait, what did you do?
It was kind of panic to me.
No, no, you gave them the, you made them go to the point.
What do you mean I made them?
You gave them the left.
Everything's okay.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
So I got res'd into another death.
Unless I know that they use all.
They use also them.
And then we, we have the Tim up here.
And wait, did I not put the other one off?
Yeah, it faced on to the left.
so
Could happen anybody I've been that I think I've sorry.
I'm starting to believe our stranger was not is not guru
Sorry, sorry, sir.
Oh, they doubled they doubled.
We can win now.
Yep, they doubled.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm best back.
I'm slowly backing out Oh, oh Oh, how did we get anyone bro?
It's ass.
Oh, no, I'm just collapsing.
Oh, it's really scary.
Um, your you're so healthy I have all here.
Oh my god.
Wait, what's going?
Why am I needing help from that?
Thank you so much.
You're so healthy.
I got you, I got you.
All right, I have all here.
I don't save it, though.
Not really.
Oh, I'm sorry.
There's a new character from us.
Yeah, we can fight this.
um so good luck with that though huge nice guru I do nice
nice nice they're TPing again
how's the story checking wait
story's not so good I think the plot is thickening we're in
the build-up guys it's a build-up we're not the middle yeah
we're not the middle arc and flip the page man go to the
next chapter the redemption arc exactly it's just a second
act but yeah remember that kill moxie got though that saved
all our lives Wait, do you have portal?
Uh...
No.
I have my old.
I have 13.
I have 10.
Okay, if you put it on point, I could maybe shoot them
through it with my old.
And then bring them back?
No.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Why don't we bring them into our spawn?
Yeah, bring them into our spawn.
Wait, yeah, yeah.
Just put it on them and I'll try to bring them to boost us.
Go, go, go, go.
Yeah, I'll speed boost the portal.
Okay, if you're good, wait, wait, wait, hang on, hang on,
hang on.
I got to line this up better.
All right, this is them.
This is them, okay?
Where is anybody?
Oh, where are they?
Bring it back.
They killed it.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
No, we got somebody.
We got somebody with it.
All right, I'm going through life.
Oh, dear.
Oh, my God.
Oh, the storm was in the sun.
The storm was bigger.
That's exactly what I wanted to happen.
did not hear that i think they just had a better strategy
you know mathematically we were up one and we we just sold i
think it was our strangest fault probably i didn't do
anything wrong i agree okay it was guru's fault oh my god
how could you die there i'm ass sorry guys i'm never gonna
do it i'm actually Uh, yeah, you kind of are so we got to
step up.
I just dump you, Keita.
Just try to do buddy Everyone relax guys.
Sorry.
I got my story.
Remember my story Who did he up that for?
They're down to support.
They're down to support
Wait, he's low.
He's half We can totally go move up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Beautiful.
They're down four.
It's literally just a strange job, Tim I'm popping off.
Well, you're popping off, Tim.
This character is so crazy.
I might move.
Or, uh, whatever.
Wait, who?
It died in something.
I think they realized they can burn it now.
Well, this.
It's okay.
Oh, my.
That's beautiful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I pulled him back too.
I pulled him back.
Bye, Puffer.
But I would live.
I count me and Puffer had literally the same idea on that
portal.
Around that corner.
I think he executed it better.
They're going to have Stormball, by the way.
Oh, we don't have enough for that.
Oh, and I'm so ready.
I'm ready for a rush.
Oh, yeah, yeah, Moxie.
Get ready.
Where are you?
Oh, my God.
Am I?
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, Moxie's dressing?
Wait, where are we?
Huge res, huge res, huge res.
Oh my god, he's flying away.
I'm scared.
Oh, I'm gonna die instantly, but I got one.
Oh my god, he's trying to shoot at Moxie, who's just flying
around.
I have a job, yep.
Good calm, Vox.
Good cause, good cause, good cause.
Yo, your taxi service is coming back, so I can...
speed you there you go nice guys perfecto oh my gosh tim if
you live this i would be very surprised the whole gang's on
you oh my god you got someone yeah i'm popping off let's go
all you on top right we're going top right that's nice we're
up to top right i'm coming top right yeah you're here with
us oh who's this guy oh my god get this guy i just found the
whole I'm just gonna touch the point or where am I gonna oh
guys guys.
Yeah, I think we got a touch point.
You're right Um I love here.
I know we needed though Maybe I'm probably gonna I got I got
here.
Beautiful
Beautiful.
Oh, oh, the invisible No, I'm short.
I think they have another storm, all right.
Oh.
Yeah, they made it facing us, though.
I think they're going to...
They're definitely going to storm on this.
Nice.
Storm's dead.
Easy.
Wait, they're Invis1.
Oh, diffed badly.
Where the fuck is the hell, though?
Yeah!
Let's go, team.
Good job, Tim.
Yeah.
That's what we do.
Oh, thank you for the raid, heavily.
Zio's so locked in.
Responsed right now.
Thank you for the raid.
I know there was another raid earlier.
Dear, thank you also for a raid.
Zio's super locked in on them.
The fights were intense.
Her kit is insane.
Like, her all is really cool, but her kit is cracked.
I just feel like she does so much damage.
Like, I said that.
She does a lot of damage.
Okay, bro.
She could technically, if you do get the combos, right, you
can, like, two to three shot, like, any non-tank.
All right, what combo are we playing now?
Oh, my God.
You have the same idea as me.
I just got the skin, too.
Are you wearing the skin?
I am wearing the skin.
Hulk one.
Do you want to Hulk her thing?
You can have it.
I'm more of a thing guy.
No, no, no.
You have it.
You can have it.
No, I already played it.
I already played it.
Oh, really?
Come on.
I'll try.
How does Storm feel?
Does she feel?
she's pretty strong she's pretty strong insane i never
thought she was a bad character but like she's even better
now in my opinion i just feel like she can get shot down
quickly though wasn't that the issue sorry what's up like
she can get shot down pretty easily by all the other hit
scan players yeah i think she might still have that but you
do get a little bit of shields when you're on yeah mode you
look so cute in your little ducky outfit oh thank you thank
you look at me You got the pool?
Oh, um...
Nope, but I got this.
Okay, alright.
I do recall...
He's making his own pool!
When I was trying to buy it.
What do you guys think about this?
Got a little rocket in my pocket.
Oh, okay, that's cute.
I like that rocket in the pocket.
Yep.
You like that, huh?
I was off the dome.
You got something to show you then.
Go, Tim, you ready?
That was in the book, I read that story.
Yeah, I'm here, bro.
Let's get in there, bro.
Let's get it.
I play Hulk once in a while.
I'll be.
Oh, that's a lot of damage, guys.
Me again.
Just heal me, forehead.
Yeah, there's a venom in your guys' backline real quick.
You guys will be fine.
Just heal each other.
We actually need heals.
I'm healing the venom.
Where's my Jeff?
Oh, my God.
I'm getting fucked up right now.
What is there?
There was a fight up on us.
Yeah, what was our healers there?
I don't want to heal you anymore.
Who's going to heal you?
Now you should take players when they say scream at heal me,
I don't heal.
I just want to know what that feels like.
I want to experience it.
It feels good, doesn't it?
Yeah, yeah, it feels really good.
Yeah, yeah.
I get it.
Thank you.
Oh, wait.
We could do the storm.
Oh, that's true.
I'm not building ult at all, but yeah, that's true.
I have it whenever.
Just let me know when you want to.
All right.
Is it me go first or you?
I don't know how that works.
Oh, you, you, you, you.
Okay.
I made my mistakes.
Oh, my gosh.
Great deals.
Oh, are you guys?
We'll be guys be five.
Yep.
Oh, man.
I'm trying to keep you alive for it.
Oh, nice.
Oh, I have it here.
Go ahead, Jay.
I'm in.
I'm in it.
Let's go.
I think I messed up.
Yeah, I was like, I don't think Stormont was supposed to be.
I was waiting.
He said go in there, so I had put my own, but then I just
hit Z.
oh wow yeah i don't know how the combo works i don't i'm
just a support player i i thought you hit z but then he's
thinking i got scared he got scared this is wrong i got i
thought i was oh no now i let now i let doki die now i'm
finished i guess i'm gonna be disappointed in more ways than
one i think i'm down there's something in common with my dad
now yeah keep me up jay I'm keeping you alive.
I'm keeping you alive.
Any more heels.
Nice.
You're fully, you're fully massive.
Thank you.
Wait, why is there?
Oh, wait.
Oh gosh, guys, there is it.
This Adam is better.
Wait, he has a heel.
He has two heels.
Why are they so strong?
No.
I die.
Oh, wait, I think it's because I was shooting.
It's okay.
I'm stupid.
No, you're not stupid.
You're my little angel.
Yo, Chad, tell Bougar.
I'm sorry about that, bro.
Okay, I have it again and I'm ready.
I'm scanning Z.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, wait, but who's first?
You are, who is first?
You or me?
Isn't it just, I don't know.
No, isn't that Jeff first?
Is it?
No, no, no.
You don't even need to.
Just press Z.
Oh, I can just, okay.
Just press, wait, who pressing Z?
Who?
You, you, you, oh, I tell me.
Shoot the thing.
Anybody?
Oh, okay.
I'm shooting Vogue as much as I can.
I got it.
No, it's our thing.
I got you, Moxie.
Who cares?
I died, Chet.
No, it cares.
Wait, the storm situation is crazy.
Oh, touchdown.
That's huge, that's huge.
That's huge.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Okay, okay.
You go.
I go first.
All right, all right.
I'm doing it.
Oh, whoa, whoa, wait, where's here?
Where's here?
This is perfect.
Where are you?
Wait, Jay, you don't even have an old?
You didn't even have an old!
Wait, wait, wait!
Jay, why would you tell her you have an old when you're
ready?
She was telling me an old!
I swear I had my old, bro.
I swear I'm not even trolling.
That's not my fault.
That's not...
The bench is kicking in already?
I swear I had my old...
No, they used the rogue old.
That's why.
it was rogue bro so i wasn't yeah yeah yeah adventure likely
story this guy's gonna live oh shit wait i might oh it's
hard to shoot help dokey guys guys guys guys i'm okay i'm
okay uh the new characters on the high ground watch out on
our high ground Oh, yeah, yeah.
She is still on the high ground.
It's okay.
We got res.
Wow.
She's one.
Nice.
Wait, there's a...
Let the dogs out.
That tank is marking.
Sorry.
We should kill Gail because he's got a res, dude.
Let her know your dog tank.
It is, yeah.
That is alpha.
Thank you.
He's a good boy.
Farm my old, farm my old, farm my old, so I can get in.
Yeah, you are, Max.
Don't worry.
I'm 75.
I am 34, but I'm trying.
See,
we don't need Sharknado to win, guys.
I went in the VOD.
I got it stolen.
They had a rogue.
Did they?
Are you sure?
I didn't see a rogue during the last...
fight um was there a road during the last fight guys yeah i
don't remember yeah i don't remember seeing one okay i'm
back sorry whips why am i widow dude what is happening vibes
yeah yeah whip yeah whips you're good oh i'm not yo my bad
guys hey oh yeah my god go ahead also it's a sound I've been
good.
Has it been better now, chat?
Has the audio been better?
Yeah, here we go.
Team up.
What team up?
Oh, okay.
That team up.
He's running back.
I didn't know you were in.
Sorry, sorry.
He thought it was a location.
Hurry up, bro.
Are you ready?
Go get him.
I'm getting him.
I'm 50.
I'm here.
That's good.
Oh!
Okay, all that damage.
I have all, I'll wait for you this time.
The third time's the charm.
I think third time's the charm.
Yeah, third time's the charm.
Oh, they do have a rogue.
Jay, you can hold first then, Doki.
You just fly over Jay.
You guys are like, I'm scared, though.
I just want to hit, I don't know how to do that.
I old did last time and I missed.
No, no, you all, and then if Storm flies on top of you,
it'll...
Okay, but then I have to figure out where he is, though.
Yeah.
yeah I'm just gonna yeah I'm just gonna yeah yeah go good go
in go in go in nice oh there you go yeah yeah ZZZ we picked
him up too let's go Tim oh my god Oh, and then they raise.
Yo, do it again?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have another ult right here, right?
I'm ready.
Goodbye, friends.
Oh.
See, I got a raise.
Oh, no.
What is happening?
I think they like ulted.
I literally, I'm not kidding.
I just got Stunlocked for like 10 seconds.
I couldn't do anything.
Rogue grabbed me.
Emma grabbed me.
Emma ulted me.
I couldn't do anything.
Oh, my goodness.
That's good.
all your cooldowns.
I was fond of him on Spider-Man.
I believe.
Let's go, Oxy.
Show him why, bro.
Wait, wait.
You guys only have solo heals, Jeff.
Okay, okay.
That's all we need.
Not just any solo heals.
Okay, I'm getting grabbed.
Thank you so much.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
Thank you so much.
Oh, my God.
I got...
Oh, oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
It's time to pull out.
Wait, out of behind.
Out of behind.
Wait, did they buff Ultron?
Did they do anything on Ultron?
No.
Uh, a little bit.
A little bit.
What did they do on Ultron?
I think they just took range on the pads.
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
Five more meters on your arm.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That's what he needed.
That's definitely what he needed.
I'm glad someone agrees.
Yeah.
The longer beam.
See you guys.
I'm going to go over here.
I'm actually going this way now.
Oh, that is...
Hey, guys, I just spawned in.
I'm going to leave now.
No one's getting credit for that kill.
Don't worry, Moxie.
I got you.
Oh, my God, you actually can't break it.
All right, your thing is gone, Moxie, so good luck.
Oh, shit.
Thank you.
Mox?
Yep.
You okay?
Help.
I'm the one that needs help.
Where's her?
Oh, shit.
Oh, I got you.
I got you.
I'm healing.
No.
Oh, I tried.
He ulted me.
It's okay.
An ult for an ult.
Oh, no.
No, see nine.
Don't worry.
I didn't see nine.
I'm on it, though.
Wait.
I'm with you, Tim.
Uh-huh.
It's okay.
Mox is coming over now.
Don't worry, Tim.
I'm leaving you.
help i'm still on it i'm dead i'm also dead i'm also dead as
well you have no tins i'm sorry guys i'm sorry i'm i'm not
gonna use my old one more life no i probably don't want to
try anybody anybody want to listen you can just go in all
and maybe get five here and then all of a sudden it doesn't
look so bad you know what they meant something just remember
that moxie i'm gonna do that and it's not gonna be it's
gonna yeah it's gonna be five all right just head to point
guys i got five of them you guys need to just deal with one
i believe papa in fact we're closer than ever did you guys
hear tim's buying us all dinner after this what oh thanks i
didn't hear that bro oh i've been starving i'll link you my
paypal yeah when you say that we mean guru right just so i'm
clear here no i got i'm broke yeah i'll take the i found a
long time ago thank you you're eating steak huh when i'm
buying that on your dime bro lobster let's get it that's
crazy bro lobster steak huh oh i would like i'll just take
some
Oh Yes, we'll be healthy right I left you Jay What what's
happening to you?
I'm just getting pinned.
I got puff.
Oh shit nice.
Oh, it was a big all my usual usual No, this is the end.
Oh, oh, we might be I think we're gone.
We're dead.
Yeah, we're my five minute spider-man old Dave rocket-ulted
at least you got it out yeah yeah yeah oh he's got the hot
guy oh you made him angry guys you're hyping this up way too
much i might get no kills yes go moxie this is it this is it
moxie this is what we've been yeah the one above all hawk
got number one hawk guy
That's not good, actually.
You got the box.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
We have res.
Oh, I don't know if I can hit.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know.
They're all on you.
No, just do it.
Just do it.
You're good.
No, bro.
If you listened there, you would have done it.
But come on.
I'm going to.
Look at this guy.
Get this guy.
Okay.
I'm outing this.
He ain't flying anymore.
Behind you, buddy.
He's renting.
That's a huge clone call.
Oh my god.
I'm getting fucked up though.
It's okay.
They're all blinded.
I blinded them again.
Guys, I'm getting bullied.
That's okay.
If you die, I got res.
If you die, you got res.
All right.
Oh yeah.
That's what I'm...
I died.
Going in the air, going in the air.
Anyone else?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's two down.
That's me.
Oh, we are diving this guy, Tim.
Yeah, he's not getting out.
It's him.
I think they also have res, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Oh my God, he's mad.
He's so mad.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Oh, crud.
I'm pretty sure they have...
Oh, never mind.
You got him.
Oh my God.
How many?
It's okay.
They definitely have...
Oh, they definitely played up.
They're it, they're it.
Nice, Moxie!
This is not how the story ends.
Nice!
New chapter, baby!
Act three, guys!
Act three!
He pulls out the Haka!
Oh, wait a minute.
Uh-oh.
Old chapter for me.
You're by yourself now.
I think they have played on.
leaving oh and that too no no no no no no no no no no no no
um you got res though uh yeah yeah 55 i got you guys i'm
scared a little i can wait oh oh that's a you're not dying
you're not dying i'm linking you oh um we're gone i have oh
but we got yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I could go in with
all for TP we got this we got this I almost have rez I
almost have res all right um so the I there's no more
there's no more out by the way there's no more out I got the
rocket can't win them all no worries no win I missed the
port of
Big res, big res, whoa!
I believe in you guys, I believe in you guys, I died though,
but I res.
I'm coming in now, I'm coming in.
I missed the portal, I forgot the timing of the portal.
Wait guys, let me swap off Hawkeye, this is embarrassing.
Oh my god.
Come back, Spider-Man at the end?
I tried.
Oh, geez.
Yeah, in the end, it was a 3-2, guys.
We, we...
Oh, so we won.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we won.
3-2, okay.
Yeah, we won three games.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're great.
GG's, y'all.
GG's, guys.
GG's, thank you for playing.
It was a lot of fun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So about the dinner, though, like, where do we send our
requests?
I gotta go, yo.
We gotta message whips.
Yeah, I'll message you.
What's his Discord?
Bro, just look him up.
You can't miss him, bro.
He's huge.
okay bye guys guys ggs guys
that was fun that was fun i'm sorry for missing all the
raids and the the subs i always get to like lock in whenever
like sponsor just to be sure that i don't miss anything but
thank you guys for those thank you again to marvel rivals
for the sponsor for today if you guys want to check out um
if you guys want to check out uh uh marvel rivals it is free
to play and all the characters are already unlockable so
like you don't have to you don't have to unlock them later
on it's all there uh and the new season 6.5 is coming out on
february 13 please feel free to click on the link pinned in
the chat or the banner in the in the channel the description
below or click the image banner uh yeah thank you guys i'll
still be streaming though i'm still gonna be streaming so
you guys uh you guys want to stick around uh i might play a
couple of i want to today's going to be a little variety day
a variety shooters day uh but yes more dokey more dokey do
not worry that's fun though trying out all the different
stuff um elsa seems very strong her alt when you figure it
out i feel like for all you just gotta like surprise people
with the alt because if you give too much distance when
you're alting like it's easier to destroy like i almost
destroyed the Jeff alone, but like, I'm not strong enough.
Like, I feel like if it was I was a DPS, I could shoot him,
shoot the ult, but like, I don't know if you guys saw it,
but I almost killed I almost killed the Jeff ult, like, just
from my left click.
I think like, if like, obviously if I was DPS, it was like
if I could have definitely destroyed it.
But like, I think like it's easier if you're surprising
people, but her damage alone is crazy, I feel.
I think her damage alone without the is already really
strong.
I am so sad.
They got rid of the colored night mode.
I'm so sad.
I want my dark blue midnight sky back.
Oh, it's just too depressing when it's just pitch black.
And makes me feel like a real D-Gen when I'm on Twitter in
my bed.
when I'm on Twitter, At 4 in the morning, it's like, I feel
like a real degenerate.
Yeah, but then when it was dark blue, I felt less sad about
myself.
I felt less sad.
Yeah, but then, like, I could cope when it's midnight blue.
When it's midnight blue, I could cope.
yeah we had a lot of funny moments today um very uh fun
group of players to play with today um i mean i've had a i i
stacked with tim a lot like i'm just happy that i didn't
have to play against moxie's hot guy even though he only
pulled it out during the last last last game but even then
as long as i didn't have to play against it that was fine by
me um yuki uh scared thank you for the twitch prime thank
you thank you uh let me catch up to all the all the
notifications i missed uh jimba thank you for the twitch
prime thank you thank you um cage thank you for the twitch
prime thank you thank you uh drato uh thank you for the
twitch prime thank you thank you bobas thank you for the
bitties thank you thank you dead thank you for the twitch
prime thank you thank you rng manga uh thumbo Thank you for
the tier one sub.
Thank you.
Shadow Flame.
Thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
Sorry if that missed the journey in the sponsor portion.
It's, like I said, I'm sorry for missing out on the
notification and all the raids too.
Like I said, Heavenly Father and dear, thank you again for
the raid.
Hope for those who are watching from their streams, I really
appreciate you guys sticking around.
But yeah, let's play a couple more games today.
um we'll play a couple of games and then i want to swap to
apex too after this we'll play a couple of rival games then
we'll swap the apex later need more practice with flying
yeah apex because my skin's out my skin is out right now
chat for those who don't know uh so let's grind a little bit
to get my watson skin My Watson skin is free.
It is free, but it's a challenge.
Like, you have to complete challenges to earn points to
receive to get the skin.
So you got to farm it.
Yeah.
Do you have a command for that?
I should make a command.
Let me make it.
All right.
Nightbot.
Let's see.
Command.
New command.
Watson.
uh yeah my song song command is the is my new cover every
time I have a new song I it's the song command all right now
it's uh back to back Elo terrorist is back all right Watson
um unlock my skin now now for for free on apex legends all
right i'm an apex uh i'm in apex now as a watson skin okay
now link it no we're playing rivals oh yeah why do this okay
i would ask moxie to play but i don't think he he has an
account in range with me because he's been grinding and i
haven't the last time i the last time i played rivals was
when i last stream rivals i've been like very very busy the
last week let's see where is it
i have so many stuff to use as commands right now all right
is it this no that's not the right video this is the right
video there we go I find the right tweet.
Watson.
And I'll update this.
There you go.
We have a lot of commands.
A lot of commands today.
Oh my god.
Where's my game?
It's not even that hot, you know.
It's Celestial 3.
Where is the video game?
Oh, Moxie went offline.
Oh, I guess he was streaming before the sponsor, right?
Holy shit, he's been streamed.
He's been streaming for 18 hours.
Oh, my God.
That's, oh, I did not expect that.
Chris Bro is grinding, grinding.
oh i really want to play mugenics i see mugenics everywhere
on my twitter feed right now i know like it doesn't seem
like my type of game because it's like was it it's like
strategy is a strategy game type deal but then you can like
you can it's apparently from the developers of binding of
isaac and yeah it's a tactical rpg and it's not my type of
game but then the one it is roguelike but it's also a
tactical RPG and that's not my type of genre but but you can
create you can inbreed the cats but there's inbreed oh shit
there's too many support players that's okay i have mantis
that's what interested you turkey bird is that the way
yes I'm not gonna explain myself I won't explain myself no
please explain yeah yeah anyway anyway i really i'm
definitely i'm gonna i'm gonna try out mugenics next week
there's a couple there's a lot of really cool games that are
releasing like this week and next week and mugenics is one
of them yeah we'll let it be a mystery you'll never we'll
never know her true intentions about mugenics oh yeah i do
have i did take a sponsored thing it's not trailer guys
person and yeah no I failed the um remember when I was like
oh I should play arc nights because I took like the sponsor
thing for arc nights it was arc I don't remember it was like
one of the anime games and then I in the end I forgot it
expired like like I was one hour late but today I shall be
responsible and it is a it's a trailer so so because it is a
trailer um It's just five minutes.
I can watch a trailer.
That's feasible.
Oh yeah, it was Arc Knight.
I can watch a trailer, guys.
And I'm doing it early.
I literally took the sponsor yesterday.
I could do it now after this game.
Can you?
Somehow I don't believe you.
I could do it.
it i think i i you know what i think it's reasonable it's
it's a reasonable tab i could be responsible three two one
all you need to do is capture the missionary oh okay i was i
my bunny hop activated it oopsie there's something that ran
oh angela we okay we have it in this that's good okay we're
double dive all right i better see some dives going on here
there better be some dives
all right nice holy fuck what the okay i they dive me all
right instructions unclear i go i dove
all right and clear he wants to dive me Jake he wanted to
they brought dive to you all right here you go I would like
them to peek me so I can you know give them oh my god
they're so set up for dive but I can't even how can I help
them oh god I'm so I'm so scared of the...
Okay, that should be fine.
Nice.
I'm just gonna let them...
Yeah, I was gonna stagger this.
Alright, nice.
Dive gone.
Dive gone, chat.
No longer have to worry about it.
It's okay.
They have egotistical DPS.
That's definitely not gonna swap off.
Swap off to play triple support.
There's no way.
It's okay.
There we go.
Maybe which one are we going to use first?
Oh, that first.
Oh, nice.
Don't worry.
Oh.
It's okay.
They technically have two support ups.
So in the end, it's like, you know, we just got the same.
amount of us you know if you think about it they use two
support us so and we used two support us so it's like very
similar it's the maps add up think about it the map adds up
okay we have to kill oh my god why did you oh my god why did
you us off why did it take us so long to kill oh
my god why did it take us so long oh my god they see nine
the math added up guys they had two support ults they used
their two support ults and we used two of our support ults
too i don't know how she see nine that was crazy i like it
all right i'll i'll do i'll be last okay me last okay i look
at that communication is key see look at that i am
communicating just feels like easier game yes because i'm
playing in gm celestial 3 it should better be easy i
literally was in the lobby with one above all, like
this better be easy.
These players do not aim like the other players.
I'll do that now, just in case, because they're fucking
fast.
Alright.
There you go.
If they...
Yeah.
They have all...
So, ooh, that's unlucky.
Oh.
Yep.
I mean, it's just on...
Oh, okay.
I was hoping that's fine.
That's okay.
We can kill her, right?
Like, technically?
Like, in theory?
Holy shit.
Okay, the double.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that's...
I have already, so...
Yeah, I didn't think like double...
I don't know, the double melee does not do much against one
cloak.
I don't know.
I felt like the double cloak just you know, double melee
against one little woman.
Didn't seem the smartest.
Oh my god.
I just got more dangerous.
said me last so all right me last all right me last and then
i don't think i have to use this honestly it would be crazy
if i had to use another support up like this is so winnable
maybe not okay yeah i didn't have to use it
Bro, that rogue...
Wait, living way too long.
See, look at that.
Restraint!
Guys!
I practiced restraint!
Oh my god, alright.
Hope I got him.
Look at that.
Look at that restraint over there!
Look at that!
Oh shit!
it's all right there is a panther behind us but it's okay i
did not know how i got that that seems so far away from us
that makes that's what makes me different from me and the
other players i think we can you know what there we go all
right and then i'll fucking leave i guess
Oh, fuck.
What the fuck?
I did not expect all that.
Oh, my God.
He's one.
How did you miss?
Me!
Oh, God.
Look, you.
Look, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
I did so much.
I swear to God they really said fuck you oh hot me
oh god oh my god please please don't wipe me they're
portaling I don't have shift
God good luck everyone um this might not I don't even know
if I can
I'm just gonna build all here I'm just gonna build all I
have all I have all it's fine it's fine Nate thank you to
the tier one so thank you thank you I will even the twitch
prize thank you mystic thank you for the bitties thank you
thank you it's okay guys I got up oh my god they're even
technically they'll need me but then if they do it'd be oh
oh they might oh no they might have needed me they might
have needed me they actually might have needed me
okay oh my god please my last my last the last thing i do in
my death damage boost
My dying breath, I gave them damage boost.
My last final breath, take it.
Take my damage boost.
There you go.
See it?
Easy.
Look at that.
Easiest win in my life.
I definitely did not struggle.
yeah with three heels behind oh look they caught up swamp
triple support nobody stopped them from playing triple
that's all i'll say nobody stopped them there's so many
support i knew they weren't going to switch to i was like i
was like thank god looking at this i can tell who has an ego
and i'm pretty sure the dp the enemy dps has an ego and they
will not swap off and i was right i knew it i knew it all
right all right let me pull up the all right it's a very
quick one it's like the usual the five like watching a uh a
five minute sponsor and then we back to rivals uh got them
thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you you can
tell the moment i saw a lord moon knight and a lord panther
i was like they are not swapping they didn't pay they oh
wait they didn't have to pay they didn't download this game
for free to play uh to swap to triple support all right
let's see a responsible person now all right let me read
what i have to do real quick uh all right how to make a
killing you must or let me grab the trailer real quick so i
can so we can watch it together chat oh it's some is this a
movie oh it's by a24 all right download and that so
responsible i know Let's see.
Oh, Glenn Poel?
Wait, I recognize that actor.
Glenn Poel.
Oh, he's a Twi- Oh, my God, he's in Spockers!
I was like, I recognize that name.
All right, what is my...
Uh...
All right, are you guys ready?
I'm going to start it.
Wait, how do I start it?
took years so professional all right yeah i'm ready for real
for real all right let's get put this over here um what is
it called 824 professional streamer been doing this for
years all right um gotta mute this and then where's my
sponsor Sponsorship.
There you go.
All right.
Huh?
Wait, does it not start today?
Oh, it's tomorrow.
Sorry, guys.
It's tomorrow.
Good thing I'm doing another Twitch stream tomorrow.
All right.
Anyway.
Apparently it starts tomorrow.
Back to queuing.
After the state of play.
Okay.
It's okay.
We're doing another Twitch stream tomorrow.
tomorrow what a professional professional streamer here i
was gonna say why can't i start it i was like oh february 12
good thing i i have i have a another twitch stream tomorrow
for a state of play yes i showed up on i did that before
university i it would be be like, um, like a holiday.
I actually did that.
It was like a holiday.
It was some Canadian holiday that I'm not aware of.
Like, uh, because like we have some weird ass Canadian
holidays that are considered federal holidays.
And then, and then like I actually showed up, like I showed
up at class and I, like, I was just like, where is
everybody?
And then the professor came to class after like 15 minutes
and she was like, what are you doing here?
I don't remember what holiday it was.
me and another student and there she's like what are you
doing here did you not read the syllabus and it's like she
pulled the did you not read the syllabus i was like no now
she does i don't read the syllabus because in university
they were every the first class there's a syllabus that
tells you what every day is gonna be that's what the
syllabus does and it tells you if there's class on that day
or like what they're gonna be learning on specific like
weeks and stuff and she got me she caught me i didn't know i
read the syllabus during finals because like i'm like why do
i need to read the syllabus where i can just show up in
class you know because i don't i i always try to show up in
class i don't wait for the powerpoints because the
professors always add additional information i have a
professor that'll do these quizzes um that were like 25% of
your grade for each quiz.
And, and like, she would like, she would, like, add
additional information that you can only get in lectures
that are not in the, like, in her specific lectures that are
not in any of the reading, like, in the reading materials or
in the PowerPoints that she uploads.
And so, like, I have to go to every class because some of
the questions will come from lectures themselves where,
like, you can't, you won't know the answer unless you come
to the lecture.
like so like it became a habit of mine to always show up to
i like i try my best to show up to lectures and like and i
felt like i didn't have to read the syllabus because like i
if i show up for class it's just gonna i'm gonna learn it
anyway like um star style they give a twitch brown thank you
there are but then what i thought it depends on the class
themselves there was some classes I did like didn't attend
fully but there were like I some I try my best to attend all
the classes uh because I wanted I was like a very studious
person back then I don't know what I did I became a vtuber
um um and then also um and then also like I remember like uh
I took a movie class before like I took like a uh movie film
class where like it's all about like learn I don't even the
job what the exact theme like the theme of the class but all
we do is just watch films and they'll give us quiz quizzes
about based off of the film and then um they're so specific
i remember like the quizzes would be and it's like 10 this
is the worst it was like 10 questions if you get one like 10
questions quiz is 25 of your grade if you get one question
wrong it's 90 percent If you get two questions wrong, you
get, it's like, you went from like 100% will be A plus, 90%
will be A, 80%, like, and then if you get two questions
wrong, um, A minus or like B plus, and then like you have to
get like at least 90, nine of the 10 questions right to be
in a good grades.
It was crazy.
It was intense.
And then one of my friends made me take the class, made me
take the class with her because, um, She was like, oh, don't
worry.
We're just going to be watching movies.
You know, because you need those classes to pad your
schedule for like EZA classes.
Like, oh, this apparently is an EZA class.
You just got to watch films.
I was like, oh, that's cool.
Sure.
Why are we not bad at Gambit?
I swear to God, if Gambit goes through, I swear, I'm not
playing Gambit.
If Gambit goes through.
I swear to God.
I'm not playing Gambit.
That's on the DPS for not fucking playing Gambit.
Oh my God.
Someone play Gambit.
I'm not playing Gambit.
That's on the DPS as well.
Yeah, because they're planning Phoenix.
That's on them.
I refuse to play Gambit right now.
and we got to run Gambit by the way why did it okay there we
put our cloak player on Gambit let's go like they must live
with their oh yeah the DPS player being like by the way
supports you gotta play Gambit now I'm like oh yeah you're
the ones that didn't ban Gambit
problem putting us like we if you don't want if you don't
want to play in scam and then fucking ban gamut i hate that
i really hate that it makes me like oh and then they blame
the supports if they we have the reason why i don't play i
don't want to do it when they don't ban gambit is because
they're just gonna blame our gambit player if their other
gambit dips them but they were the ones then and then we're
like well why didn't you ban gambit i
feel like okay if they're running... Oh, no.
If they are...
Okay, wait.
They're not running...
They're not running mag, so I can actually...
Everybody's playing rogue now.
I see a lot of rogue players.
I've noticed a lot of rogue players now.
Oh, my...
Okay.
I feel like Cloak would be strong.
Cloak is very strong now in this meta for some fucking it's
just oh no that's unlucky i'm gonna push him up just in case
where's our thor oh there he is i'm gonna say where the fuck
did he go oh that's good oh that's unlucky our gambit got
hit Yam it's never gonna fold soon Yam it never fold Yep
I knew it Oh I knew that was gonna happen Oh now he demands
Oh my god He demands triple support
Oh Yep, and then he demands triple support.
Oh, wow.
Who would...
Who would have thought?
They're like, oh, now we need triple.
I don't know if I can save him.
That's the thing.
Do we have Gambit never foes?
Oh, that...
Okay, not now, but alright.
I hope we get...
Oh, we got this.
Okay, we got kill.
We got kill.
Okay, that's good.
I was gonna say, I hope we get a kill for that.
Oh, my God.
And they're running triple.
Only we ban Gambit.
At least we ban Loki.
Thank God.
Oh, God.
Does it hit me when I'm up here?
Where is that?
Almost have it here.
I can use it here.
There you go.
I saved him.
Oh my god, he stunned me.
But it's okay.
Oh my god, I still made it back!
I don't know how.
I still made it.
it back okay um all
right it's fine okay it's fine everything is so i'm gonna
let her build all i'm gonna let her build all she really
needs it this is more important i'll heal a little bit for
him but she needs to have all right now like actually right
now there you go she has it oh it's fine she has all i
believe oh fuck please gamut never falls gamut never falls
okay that's good that's good
gamut never falls gamut never falls gamut never falls there
you go gamut never falls gamut never falls there you go
there you go there you go there you go
it's fine i have all here oh my god they swapped off triple
oh my god cabin dead they swapped off cabin it's winnable
goodbye get me out of here get me out of here
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
I help you.
You help me.
What happened to the code?
The code has been broken.
Oh no.
Oh why are you all running from my...
And if only you were in the...
You want to go in?
You got...
Oh, I guess not.
If he actually healed me while we were doing this, it would
have been one of them.
It would have been like...
We could have capped that.
Oh, shit.
He's so dead.
I'm fucking leaving.
Like...
Holy shit, unless...
Alright.
Can we get the squirrel, Sam, please?
Geometry!
Simple geometry will save you!
I don't know if our daredevil is alive.
Okay, he has all for sure.
I'm fucking...
I'm worried about that.
Alright, two four fights.
Oh, okay.
Man,
this guy has a lot of suggestions right now.
Gambit never folds.
Holy!
What is that?
going on in there i hope we're winning oh we are okay
hello that's not fair we keep each other alive there we go
there we go see our little we keep each other alive We keep,
we can keep each other.
Okay, like, I don't know about that now.
I'm trying to keep each other alive right now.
Hello, Gambit.
Hello.
I live.
All right, all right, all right, all right.
The amount of stuff I'm doing for my Gambit.
Hello guys, um, point.
Point.
Maybe I should play Gambit.
Of course your story's in Worship.
I don't think our Gambit plays Gambit.
I think I'll play Gambit.
I don't think I'll play Gambit.
I have a feeling they don't play Gavit.
I don't want to play Gavit!
Oh my god.
It has too much with gambol just fucking rip it like the
hesitation is too much when they get it they hesitate they
like hold it for some fucking reason they hold it as a
counter on and i'm like bro just rip it you're supposed to
use it before they defensive i'll
all right here we go all right here we go we do this i just
didn't want to play gambit i wish we banned gambit
We're in chat.
Oh.
Well, it's still a critique.
There's too much hesitation for it.
Alright, there you go.
It's fine.
That's unlucky.
Oh my god.
I'm missing my...
I haven't done this in so long.
I am missing my cards, though.
Are you serious?
Yeah, he's fucking dead.
He's fucking dead.
Yo, this door is fucking out.
Unlucky.
I don't think it's a Thor problem.
I think.
We don't even need to play Gabman.
They don't even have Gabman, to be fair.
I didn't want to use that, but whatever.
Do we kill anything with it?
I'm going to rip at the moment.
let's fucking go go in there we go is there anything else in
there we're five
yeah you just rip it there that's it you literally use it no
hesitation you get it you use it you don't fucking you don't
think about it because you want to use it with the first
advantage oh my god i fucking yeah i didn't see the rogue i
was gonna kill the squirrel girl
i would have done that i knew the rogue was below me i saw
like i just saw the squirrel girls like what the fuck yeah
jump i thought she was my wife how could she just kill me
like that
there you go
oh god that means too aggressive for some reason oh my god
okay if he lives that like oh he does where are you oh no
i'm lucky i might as well die i might have died no don't oh
my gosh i was gonna say let me die or he's just gonna
prolong taking my life
sorry when did i chase other women i've been so loyal
Does he have ult?
I don't remember if he used it.
What the fuck?
He got deleted so fast.
And I want to use heal cards, but what else can I do about
it?
We have... I want to use it, but...
There you go.
See?
Alright.
I saw Daredevil ult, and I was like, it's time.
I feel like I'm being watched.
Who is he fighting anyway?
He's trying to...
Wait, is it the squirrel girl?
But she's still behind us!
Okay, I got it.
What about the squirrel girl, guys?
Is she still there?
Like...
I can't tell!
Oh, that's unlucky.
That's fine.
I'm gonna stay in that corner.
I mean, that's five.
Oh, that's a lot.
That's a lot of stuff, guys.
I think we just die.
I'll grab old charge.
I was like, wow, that's a lot of us.
They all press.
They all press Q.
We just walk and then we win.
How many others were there?
Just a lot.
matter there you go i cleaned that luckily i had clean oh
luckily oh that's unlucky like we couldn't do anything about
that i mean i have a lot here i'm just gonna wait why did i
i'm not gonna what okay i'm waiting what the fuck are we
doing we're in celestia with solo team the whole team i mean
yeah avoid this guy first we win
Oh, wait.
Okay.
There you go.
Alright.
That's unlucky.
They used the...
I mean, I know all it's to...
I mean, we could kill this guy.
We didn't actually kill him.
No, never mind.
We cannot.
We cannot kill him.
holy don't let him he just literally walked up okay maybe
our story is a problem too but we gave gambit
i mean we waited that's the thing we didn't have anything oh
i wait is there anyone on the other side
oh bro can we not go through that fucking dead trap Can we
not go through this death trap?
We went through the death trap.
Sorry, I got...
Alright, to be fair, I...
When he said that, I was not paying attention.
I will say when he said that, I was just like, that...
I was just like, lol.
I could have...
I should have focused up.
Is he not wrong?
I need all charge.
I hope she lets me build all charge here.
Like, we literally need a win with Milo.
So I need him to let me build all here.
Oh my god.
Literally just.
I literally just needed.
I just needed like a little bit more all charge.
Yeah, we love.
These.
This door is just firing this.
Sit Thor.
When is 1916?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
No, that guy.
Yeah, that guy ain't it.
1916.
Oh, wow.
If only they bad gambit.
If only.
Thor was something.
Yeah, let me avoid that.
this guy bro he like fucking was 1v1ing some guy by himself
and didn't even kill him
oh i'm banning gambit i really i just don't feel like
playing gambit they haven't nerfed him for like two seasons
for like two seasons i'm like tired of that i i'm like i'm
like I'm, like, so tired of Gambit Olds.
I'm tired of Gambit Never Foods.
But, and I'm tired.
Oh, you're on 200 ping?
Go say something.
Say, you can say in the team chat.
If I knew, I'd pick up Gambit.
Sometimes I don't catch chat messages.
Also, 200 ping Gambit.
You're fucking...
crazy for that.
Limon!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
I hope you had a great... I saw you were playing Mugenics
earlier.
Is it fun, guys?
Oh my god, thank god.
Bad Gambit.
Yes.
Yes!
Yeah, I'm trying to check it out.
I'm planning on checking out next week.
I'm not a tactical RPG person, so we'll see how it goes.
But like, everyone's saying it's like really fun.
So, I don't mind.
I really want to try it and just see how it is.
The music is banger.
I know it's roguelike.
I like roguelikes, too.
I heard it's a really, really long game.
And apparently the intro is like a Simpsons intro.
we're like uh it's a simpson intro so uh yeah maybe look
maybe i'll do cloak yeah i'm gonna say look look double
click oh good yeah it has like 200 plus different intros
every time you boot it up man hey y'all just play some more
marvel rivals
two to three more names of rivals and we're swapping the
apex.
Look at my skin.
Oh my god, not this map.
I hate this map so much.
Yeah, but never.
I'm just so tired.
It's like PTSD.
Every time I hear Gavin never fuzz, I get trauma.
Yes, I have official skin in the apex.
That's why I want to check it out on stream.
Manny, thank you for giving the tier one sub to Lama.
Yeah, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Alright.
She's dead.
Oh, I knew it.
Oh.
I'm gonna say.
Just gotta enjoy the...
Yasu enjoyed the fucking...
Oh, yeah.
Like that simple geometry I just did there holy shit how did
he like instantly lose all his HP there's crazy all right
guys I made a bubble but no one used my bubble guys makes me
sad oh my god is this no it's a different Thor it's a
different I was gonna say I hate it you know those moments
when all right let's go
all right oh no oh no oh no no i got dragged out i wanted to
like fly away but it got me before i could fly that sucks
actually got me before i could fly oh no i don't even think
we could make it
i'm at 91 i don't know if i can grab
dead I couldn't if I had all I would use it there everyone
keeps running away from my bubba what
let's hope I'm okay I'll grab get rid of this first there
you go oh nice there you go see they're that easy well we
won our first fight guys Congratulations.
We did it.
Oh my god.
This, I think the two DPS are dueled together.
That's why they're running.
Who would fucking, why would you one trick magic and, and,
and then duel together to force us to run two melees?
That's so fucked up.
That, that is messed up.
So we have to play with two melee characters.
We have no choice.
That's actually crazy.
There's no choice.
I'm trying.
Let them have fun.
We can't even do anything about it.
The fact that...
Oh my god, I still can't believe it.
It's their date, dude.
Don't ruin it for them.
Where's the cart?
I'm like, where is it?
Alright, I'm going to be here.
Alright, watch this.
Oh, not yet.
Not yet.
It's going to be here soon.
It's going to be right here.
I'm waiting for it.
Oh, not yet.
Not yet.
All right.
Very surprising.
It's not here yet.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, all right.
That's good.
We have this for Legendary.
No Legendary.
Any moment now.
It's gonna be right here But you shouldn't let me farm up
though
Stand in the buffer!
Don't worry
There you go, there you go, there you go, there you There it
is, there it is Aw man, he jumped down
There it is, there it is There it is, there it is We wait
There you go.
I saved us.
Oh my god.
We're saved.
You're welcome.
I'm a hero.
I'm actually a hero.
Well, I can still... I'm still a hero.
Oh, don't you can't see me?
Still a hero?
Still a hero, technically?
He's dead, but like, I did my job.
Oh, they're teleporting.
No.
Oh, that's not good.
Where's my team?
It's not good.
It's right here, right here.
I'm right here.
Whenever you're ready.
All right.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
We have portal.
last or first oh no last oh that's okay strange do your
thing we can't stall no we cannot get it get it wait when
did they have the mood oh my god it is possible I'm a hero
I'm actually a hero I'm actually a hero
Look at that!
That cloak saved our lives!
My cloak fades, saves, and saves the game.
Look at that.
Actual hero.
He got the...
It's because like, I faded the... I faded the ult too.
So we're able to do it.
Good shit.
Good job, Doki.
Good job.
I'm patting myself on the back.
Good job, Doki.
Excellent job.
Thank you, Doki.
Thank you.
I know.
I know, Doki.
You did so good, Doki.
Thank you, Doki.
Three
seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Why doesn't Cloak have any legs?
Oh, that's a good question.
I would say his figure skating.
emote is pretty silly.
I don't think I saw.
I don't have it.
I don't know.
I don't have it quit.
But he has a figure skating emote.
Because like a dagger has one.
And it's just he's just gliding.
Apparently in the comics he actually does have legs.
That's why like he lost them in the war.
Adam took the legs.
You know?
It's because Adam took it.
Okay.
I'm gonna And I can make sure he took the legs.
There's someone behind us.
Okay, I thought there was someone behind us.
I was getting scared.
Holy fuck, he got deleted.
Oh my god.
Bro, tanks are getting deleted so fast.
I don't think the Loki and I have stopped left clicking yet.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh my god, the one time I...
decided no he's fucking dead i mean you could copy me
whenever if you want to give never mind oh he fucked up he
messed up fight was lost
he wasted the up what the what i mean share okay what is our
hella doing
All right, I mean, that's fine.
Okay, he has to use it fast or, like, the alt's going to run
out soon.
Oh, they're using...
Don't worry.
I got my own, too.
Oh, no, I wasn't in close for...
Oh, that's unlucky.
Oh, um...
I think the two melee thing is catching up on us now.
I think having two melee kickthroughs, it's not working no
more.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, shit.
We stopped it.
That's a lot of damage.
There's a lot of damage, guys.
I don't know.
if i can i'll i'll do this
what the he still pulls me where was it
um i know it's not there is something wrong okay there you
go okay all right one from one melee to the next but at
least the other melee is a tank you know it's the it's the
little things guys it's another melee but this time it's a
take melee which means more hp we need that we need that
guys
oh my god oh my god i'm not the i'm not the oh i'm not the
oh i got scared of going up i me i could have i should have
pushed it higher what i was behind the oh my god i was
behind the bus
i think guys i think the two melee might have might have
fucked us over i i think i think the two melee i mean
looking at stats alone yeah no the other team really
deserved it more yeah i don't realize the thing all goes
under the buses maybe yeah looking at stats wise i think i
think maybe their dps was just a lot better just just a
maybe thank you and this thank you very much brad thank you
thank you i really appreciate it thank you so all right
let's i'll do one more actually yeah actually you know what
i think it's time i need to say how i'm streaming for you
all right yeah yeah i want to make sure i don't burn out
before we get there i think it's time pulling it up it's
apex time it's been a while does apex have drops right now
or no guys does apex have drops right now or no yeah and
then after apex we go into overwatch apparently jetpack cat
has been like bad non-stop in rank because he's too strong
john halo is the strongest dps and jetpack cat is the
strongest support yeah he's been bad non-stop in rank guys
is there drops right now there's no okay there's no drops
all right i don't i'll get rid of that apex legends all
right let me go pull it up uh my apex is loading right now
okay all right here we go apex time back to where my career
began
Apex.
I just put decent amount of people on at the moment.
Yeah, but this is what made my B-tubing career.
Oh my god.
I don't understand.
Why can I still not access anything?
I What's going on with my account I still can't access shit
Oh no I'm still I'm still in debt to the apex Mafia I'm
still in debt No I just wanted No I want a city anniversary
I can't even Okay okay Are these the challenges?
What are the challenges Okay, I have a mercy.
Okay, they've dealt 3,000 damage as a recon legend.
Okay, restore.
Alright, we got this.
We got curse.
We did not change.
Did my category not change it?
No, I did.
I did do it.
Alright, let me, I'll reboot it and see if it works.
Last time I did it, it didn't.
So, like, I don't know.
They broke my...
I'm like now in Apex debt.
Ever since...
ever they gave me my skin but at what cost at what cost
uh now oh minus nine thousand nine hundred and ninety nine
dollars through the apex mafia
i'm surprised there's no oh there you go gold one gold two
yeah it's crazy wow Wow, my new, wait, is it actually, wow,
I only did rank one tier, that's great, you know what's
funny, some predator players got deranked to silver, and
like, I'm like, I think that's fucking funny as hell,
because like, some of them actually deranked to silver, and
I'm still in gold, baby, I just need 29 RP, higher, oh my
god, wait, I'm so Some people were trying so hard to grind
the plat as well.
I'm literally like almost one deer away from plat.
This rank, by the way, this rank is where some of the pred
players are at right now.
Gold and plat is where some of the pred players are at.
That's so fucking funny.
Didn't even need to try.
My SPMM is still high.
Let's go.
Still got my SPMM, baby.
Still got it.
Never punished.
Wins by doing nothing.
But there's the, where's my, guys look, my skin.
You can get this for free, guys.
You can get this for free.
You just gotta complete the challenges for it.
So there it is, that's me.
Look.
That's me.
Right here.
Oh, my God.
That's literally me.
So, yeah.
Let's do some more of the challenges.
Is this part of the challenge?
Okay, seven anniversary.
Deal a thousand.
This gives me points, right?
Get top ten.
Deal 500 damage.
Battle pass.
Get five headshots.
Uh, yes.
Okay, that's good.
Dailies.
Play.
Okay, I want to do the recon legend.
I'll do Bloodhound.
bloodhound is oh wait not rank not rank though i heard i
heard rank is not fun right now so uh let's chill a little
bit in rank yeah let's chill a little i'll wait i don't
think i want to get in there at the moment oh my god oh i
think it's me i'm like i skewed it up if i do pubs does
lower my sp my account is so pure right now it's in it's
like literally like untouched almost untouched from all the
stacking i've done it's actually so pure
that's good as long as pubs doesn't uh as long as pubs
doesn't ruin my uh ruin my uh untainted spmm
It has history in it.
It's generational.
Actually, yeah, generational.
Oh, let's see.
Yeah, I won't play Bloodhound.
It's like pure blood.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god, we're almost...
We have, like, we are not, like, aggressive.
Oh, shit.
Hey, Walmart employer.
That guy looks like a gamer.
wait actually maybe i can ask some of my friends to play let
me check what happened
all right i mean that's it's fine i didn't want to play that
game anyway and they're like you have it may have end are
you fucking kidding me they saw my teammates i was like oh
wait i actually have real teammates and they're like think
again like they're like don't keep bird winning the teammate
gotcha i don't like that that ain't right don't keep bird
having a teammate that can actually shoot their gun
oh can you farm it in wild card really oh unlucky i didn't
know you could farm it in wild card Oh, it's not as sick no
more.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, I forgot.
Let me unpin that.
Unpin this message.
Monster done.
And 20K?
Wait, there's 20K badges now?
That's like, excuse me, 20K badge?
Oh, you mean 20.
Oh, 20 bombs.
Okay, 20 bombs.
20,000 damage.
Bro.
You meant the 20 bomb.
That makes more sense.
I was like, 20,000?
I don't even think there's 20,000 in this lobby.
Alright, let me see.
I can message my...
I see if any of my friends are online.
Um...
I have to look for the server.
Wait.
Are they online?
No.
Unfortunately, my...
my old apex buddies are not online they're all asleep right
now unfortunately okay that my season 2 apex wins on
bloodhound all right here we go unfortunately my
is it me is it but is it all
right round three guys
The account is too weird.
It may have ended.
Okay.
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
Maybe I'll just play wild card.
It was not my go-to mode after yesterday.
But, like, maybe it'll be different this time.
I won't say it's my go-to game mode.
Because it's pretty fucked up.
But, like, maybe it'll be different.
Maybe.
oh yeah oh wait you're right fuse is open oh god that's
gonna be so fucking chaotic fuse is back guys he clocked
back in wait you can only play ranked there's no way there's
no okay temple you're with me you have to be with me yeah he
came back from retirement i am not playing rank when i saw
all those i'm literally in gold to gold to slash on the
borderline of Gold 1.
And it's like, that's where all the Pred players are lurking
right now.
I'm not going to be in some five minute montage, Like a five
minute clip of one game.
Under mode than rank.
Don't do this.
Don't.
Don't mean.
Yes, for the pro players, there's no, there's no meme it's
memes right now yes for the pros okay this is it this is it
is if he was even good for this game mode i feel like i saw
a lot i just can't it's too fast octane was so fast this is
it it's a you problem Doki you were the problem no my cow
was too pure it was too fucking pure
there's me you tell I don't play oh my god it's literally
just pubs it's just it's just one yeah but it's gonna be too
soon one whole kill Look at that guy's jealous.
Yeah, I know you're jealous right now.
One kill.
That's my streaming.
Oh, no!
No!
Not here!
my god not here oh
my god not oh my god i didn't even see that guy you're not
even the whole team ran at me oh my god not here back to
hell i hate this place so much i actually hate this area
have it
oh god not here not here please anything but here I
don't even know I don't even see them I'm saying high ground
you don't there's no way I'm leaving this area.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
By reflex, I went bottom, right?
You ain't getting me over there.
Oh.
That's awkward.
I'll grab that, though.
Oh no.
No!
You're not getting my body!
Get out of here!
I needed that self-risk.
I knew it.
I was just like...
Do I leave high ground?
Okay, this is less hell.
I just don't want to have a havoc right now.
Oh my god.
It's okay he does it.
There you go.
Worth it.
Oh, you two again.
Two kills.
Guys, two whole kills.
It's so worth it.
Wait, I told you.
I told you I could get it.
Two whole kills.
I hate this place so much.
I fucking...
I hate this area.
Oh my god.
I'm going to my buddy here.
I'll fight with you.
Don't worry.
I shall no longer fight with you.
I...
I was like, don't worry, bro.
I'm here for you.
Alright, no longer shall I fight for you.
Where is...
Oh my god, what?
I don't fucking know.
Maybe it'll hit something.
Okay.
Is there anyone behind me?
paranoid right now.
Jesus Christ.
Instantly abandoned.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
You think they're still fighting in there?
Are you fucking...
Who's shooting at me?
Who is it?
I still got it, though.
That movement was pretty clean.
Oh, no.
Anastasia.
you fucking crazy man bro this guy has an R9 why would you
I'm so fucked I hear him too oh my god
are you fucking where I don't like being here oh my oh my
god get me out of here oh my god
where are you like it
i'm not playing you what am i guys i told you two whole
kills let's kill i i don't know i guys i i'm not a fan of
wild card i'm i i'm not it's just i'm not a fan of landing
in that spot that spot fucking sucks like it actually sucks
so much wherever you look at go wherever you look at there's
nowhere to go i think this this character is really strong
in this game mode they took me to hell they they took me to
hell they're like welcome to hell Doki welcome
They're like welcome back Doki brain.
Why don't we land in your favorite spot?
Oh my god, you know, I trust my randoms.
Maybe this random won't land me to wherever the fuck that
was again I did not consent to be in that area
He's gone.
No, we're so far.
It's on the other side.
We're literally the other side of the map from that area.
That was the... That area is actually the fucking worst area
to ever land.
Like, the fact that, like, my teammate picked that, too.
It's literally the worst one.
Out of all the places they could land, that has to be the
worst spot of them all.
Out of every fucking spot that exists here.
Is there anyone even down there?
I don't think so.
I think there's a fight here.
I want to fight that though.
Okay I'm just gonna go there.
Oh my god, they're coming.
Oh my god All right, let the ambush begin guys Oh my god, I
hear them this time.
We will be the third party here
What the?
I was thirsting you.
I don't care if you weren't even part of this.
Wait, I hear it.
I don't care.
I hear another, Rez.
I hear you.
Oh, that's my teammate.
I'm sorry.
The trigger finger happened.
Oh my god, it's a cage.
Wait, they're back here.
Where they're behind us, aren't they?
Oh my god, they landed here instead.
Might become the thing you destroy.
Oh,
he queued.
That could have been our kill.
He's literally one.
What the fuck?
On the high ground?
There you go.
Ooh, you dirty dog dancer.
All right, is there any extra ammo?
I'm a little poor in ammo right now.
Where are...
Holy shit!
See?
Look how nicer this is.
Look how much calmer this is, guys.
Wow!
Doesn't this feel like so much nicer?
I think my team will be fine, right?
It's fine.
Worth it.
Oh my god, I leave.
It's okay.
I'm high, girl.
But where?
Oh, here.
Oh, and there where is this land okay it's a what the fuck
it's okay I'm gonna crack them I feel like I'll just stay
here it's fine I still have shield cells oh wait is that car
oh fuck wrong gun that's like wait a minute that's
Nice.
I'm running out, though.
He's gonna be fine, right?
There you go.
Like, I'm willing to stay here.
I can stay here forever.
Oh, I wanted to Kobe that and see if that worked.
We're sort of out of...
You know what?
I believe in our team.
What if, guys, they're gonna run out of ammo eventually,
too.
I believe they'll run out of ammo faster than we were.
will run out of ammo team oh my god look look at that never
punish see look at that okay oh shit i didn't even
oh no oh no oh no he's one he's resin he's resin
it's okay 13 seconds oh no oh no come on one second one
second oh shit there you go there you go I said told you oh
no oh no it's okay it's okay it's okay I would live for us
do not worry I will live for us do not worry oh fuck it's
fucking right that's right
That's fucking right!
Okay, I...
What was that?
What was that plan?
I don't know what the plan was.
I don't know what the plan was for that guy.
That guy was so confident.
Look at that!
It feels so much nicer.
Doesn't it, chat?
hell hole that we were dragged into doesn't this feel much
more common and exciting
does this feel a lot i get to actually play the game holy
that's wild for wild card
where is he going okay that fact that like
oh no i don't i don't like that there are okay nice we
thirsted that guy i don't know what the plan was for oh my
god he's actually one did he die from storm no he's just
dead dead
where oh shit oh shit i don't know i want to be over here
anymore.
Oh my god!
Okay, he missed, he missed.
He missed though.
All right, we got one.
Okay, we gotta help him.
Oh my god, his goal is just to live.
All right, but what if you don't live we know you're by
yourself bro oh i think he got oh my god he is not okay i i
don't know man i don't know if i want to go that i feel like
we should just go to zone bro i yeah i don't i don't know if
we should chase him it's a little too he's gone god yeah i'm
like i don't know if i want to leave
Yeah, where do we go?
Alright, maybe they'll kill you still seven.
Hello, guys.
Oh, never mind.
You shot.
Oh, no.
You shot our Valhalla.
That's unfortunate.
Our Valhalla got shot.
Alright, so what's the plan?
Huh.
Hmm.
I don't know if we should, like, make sure.
our presence known right about now all right oh there we go
i do feel a little naked up in the sky it is very a little
scary wait nobody's here oh god oh god not here
All right, nice.
Holy shit, you're wild for that.
I'm gonna check behind us.
In case anybody wants to do a little flankerunny behind us.
I'm very paranoid.
This guy is crazy if you're still peeking that.
No one flying?
That's good, no flyers?
No flyers?
All right.
No flyers.
What the fuck?
Oh, man.
I did not expect that.
It's like, where did he come from?
Wait, this zone is...
I want to make sure I don't waste my bullet.
I do wish I have a scout right now.
I feel like definitely be a lot helpful.
Okay.
If there's like one teeny scout.
Oh, you're so lucky.
We actually are so lucky.
Oh.
Did you hear that?
Oh, oh my god.
I almost fell down.
What's that?
Oh, we're next to zone.
We are next to zone.
Five squads.
I don't know.
I'm not shooting anymore.
I'm only 124 bullets.
I'll wait.
I'm patient.
I can wait.
You mean it's like this in zone?
Yeah, this is in zone.
What the fuck?
Wait, this is in zone.
Whatever I take the wild card.
Do you think they'll know?
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Oh, I should have grabbed the third one.
It heals my teammates, too.
I got a little greedy.
I definitely got greedy.
Last squad.
Yeah!
See?
Look at that.
Is that crazy?
We went because we didn't land in the hell room.
that look at that i told you we didn't land in the hell room
the hell drop as long as you don't spawn in hell it is
winnable it is winnable chat it's all it takes all right
maybe i can queue up home now my oh she's still got that's
me for it thank you for the 10 gift themselves thank Thank
you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
All right.
How many points did I get from that?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Challenge.
I got... Oh, I completed two.
I played two.
Wait, that counted?
Oh, yeah, I did.
The hell in here.
All right.
Two deal... Wait, they're not?
I feel like I did deal 250.
Well, that's where...
I feel like I did do 250, but they are not.
that yeah i did not with with like r9 oh lmg god sorry look
i felt i always feel like r9 is an lmg all right top 10
revive oh wait this is automatic if you queue wild card
you're always top 10 because there's 10 squads i just
realized that real squad mates okay pk uh all right revive
squad mates twice all right what about here i complete
anything here shield bat play 15 all right we gotta get
these all right we gotta get uh all right maybe this time
wait maybe this time i'm allowed in here maybe maybe i'm
allowed okay now maybe if i'm doing pubs
all right now it's just every gun possible ah broken meal
yeah i was gonna say gross
Broken moon.
No!
I needed...
I wanted to get the battle pass.
What the fuck do I play now?
I'll do Catalyst.
I like her.
I like her new update.
Her new update's fun.
Alright.
We are like the most defensive team.
We got this, guys.
Surely.
This time, I'm allowed in.
Alright, here we go.
We got this.
Anyone else around us?
No, we're cool.
Oh, wait, never mind.
We're not cool.
We are no longer cool.
I should go over and help my teammates.
I'm humming over Don't worry The hero is here I got you
There we go See I told you the hero is here
Okay it was PK right yeah
There we go
Okay he's got to find another door now there
we go fucking idiot another one holy shit I was not ready
for round two
oh wait yeah grab this not me though okay it's okay they're
fighting each other I should help
but what if
okay I should help my team oh my god really Jesus how the oh
my god this is so annoying there we go a door another one I
still got it I still got it fucking easy
Play.
That was smart.
What's that?
That was a fucking smart-ass play I did there.
Through that nade, knew he had there's nowhere else to go.
Planked him from behind.
Didn't need an R9.
I should get my R9 right now.
Didn't even need an R9 for that shit.
That's it.
I'm going all in.
My 301.
Alright.
Is that it?
Still got it.
Still fucking got it.
Anyone?
Oh, they're all like over there.
We're sort of safe.
Yeah, head over.
Let's go.
Alright, let's fucking go.
Oh, yeah.
I told you.
Took me a while to get it back.
But I told you guys.
You know, best part?
Nobody's gonna respawn behind me.
That's the best part, too.
Alright, here we go.
I have no idea where the enemy team is.
I trust my bloodhound with my fucking life.
I'm not jumping that.
Yeah, they actually stay dead.
Isn't that crazy?
Hmm.
Fuck.
I'll take your light ammo, though.
If he doesn't take the flatline, I'll take it.
Yeah, takes it.
Alright, then I'll take this.
Oh yeah, too many shields.
Oh wait, I need that actually.
I forgot to enhance my light gun.
Almost forgot that was a feature.
Staying dead?
What a wild concept, I know, right?
That's crazy.
That I get to experience that.
Actually, I need a shield battery.
I have none.
Oh, they're fighting.
Oh, you know what that means.
Oh.
Is he gonna go through that?
That would be very surprised.
Well, I lift.
Oh my god, that's a window.
Oh, what?
Just in case.
Where did they go?
What the fuck?
Excuse me?
That's another squad.
Oh my god, you're crazy for peeking that.
You are insane.
I have an upgrade.
I know I should- I don't like using F1.
It just takes two to die.
To F1 it.
That's why I don't use it.
I have a...
I just realized I have a naked R9.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, I messed up.
Oh, I didn't...
I didn't realize there were so many people there.
That's fine.
I can...
That's a third party.
Oh, my God.
Please, Bloodhound.
You gotta live.
For us, Bloodhound.
For us.
That was a third party.
Bloodhound.
You can't 1v1 this.
You gotta live.
No!
no he's fucked they're gonna chase him yeah no i actually i
thought i thought i threw away my 2x on the r9 and then it i
didn't realize i didn't yeah i forgot about that that was my
bad it fucked with me because i was like that's somebody
carbide i was like no he's super dead there's no way there's
no way he's so fucking dead i don't i feel like you're gonna
find him wait unless unless oh he's out he's he's coming
back bro what the fuck okay now to crawl this way oh my god
bro bro bro i'm trying my best bro bro i'm trying my best to
crawl to you bro oh my god he's not coming back he's not
coming because you think he's gonna come back to me he's
coming back oh bro you're not gonna get that hot seeking
no does he even have the meds I don't even think he has the
meds for this There's no way Oh he's risking it all To find
extra meds You're so stupid Oh my god This zone hurts too
doesn't it This zone too This guy is crazy He forgot that
was my door He forgot Oh wait He has He got a res beacon for
it though That's actually really good Please don't make us
Don't res us here Oh wait actually Oh we're close to the
zone Actually it's 5 He's like Whose door is that Okay
that's good The zone is It's slow It's slow because we're at
the edge of it too That's actually really good Yeah That's
such a we're on the slow side so we're fine theoretically
we're fine i always believed guys i never doubted for a
second i have zero attachments that's right i never doubted
all right here we go i find some light i'll grab it for the
carbine i think i need it Never doubted my bloodhound for a
second.
I knew leaving me to die was the right move.
Alright.
Oh, man.
I don't think we're winning this stuff.
We're sort of like...
Oh, kidding.
We sort of have like...
Nothing right now.
Oh, it...
It did reset.
Oh, it did reset.
I have zero attachments, but...
But the bins reset itself.
So there's hope.
Replicator incoming.
Let's exercise our craft.
I just gotta figure out where they are.
I mean, yeah.
I think, yeah, you're right.
Here we go.
Let's hope they're not right behind us or anything.
That'd be so awkward.
Wait.
actually oh wait no because they won't see it you know fuck
okay wait no actually I thought they won't know because it's
invisible remember chat it'll be invisible so they won't see
it and then they'll come here and then they'll open this and
they'll get hit by the spike.
Should I need that?
I should need that.
I don't know what I picked up but I need that.
We can actually...
We don't want to guard the...
They haven't destroyed.
Infinite ammo.
I don't need it.
I don't know if I want the Kraber.
not if it's i don't know i don't know it's a little too
risky it's like craver it's a little too risky right now
infinite app yeah but like it's it's way too risky to do
this but the content don't keep i don't even know if these
are coming from here i swear to god they end up being in
front of us i swear to god is it worth it is it risk but the
clips you're right you're right he got it the bloodhound
took it wait but i could grab this though
infinite ammo oh my god we could do it
hey you're right Oh, you guys were right.
Hey, guys.
You guys might be right.
See, guys.
Who said I was washed?
And he gave my touch.
Doesn't matter how long it's been.
Just, I don't know.
I'm so humble.
I'm just a natural.
Doesn't matter how long it's been.
It's like riding a bicycle.
Mr. McFluffy can't think of it.
Dear, it was so humble.
My Oshi is so humble.
Look at that.
easiest game of my life why past doki would have done it
you're right i would have finished the game in five minutes
you're so right you're so fucking right chat the past retro
doki could have completed that game in five minutes
my Watson skin, guys.
You can hit those headshots just like that.
See that?
Just like that.
You too can also hit those headshots.
Alright, got a top 10, play 5.
You know, I could grab like two more points here.
I did not raise anybody.
Fuck that.
Alright, let's see.
Is it the shoes?
Don't...
Alright.
By player.
Oh, I can do.
We'll get another top 10.
10 it should be easy okay i need to grab a pk next she hits
those i sure do that's me all right we'll do a wild card i
think it's the easiest to grab the pk what was it oh you
don't buy it's free it's actually free so all you have to do
is grind out your dailies here the dailies challenges these
points and anniversary legend challenges all of these and um
and then you can unlock it you basically unlock it in the
past i automatically get top 10 because wildcard only has 10
squads yeah and it's free too i
be like holy shit the double caustic
wait that's cheating it's not cheating we're trying to get
my skin.
Oh, get that, guys.
What can I say?
Come back, baby.
I heard you guys were like, you should do it for content.
I was like, you're right.
Toki always does it for content.
She never backs down from content.
all right here we go where are they going where are they
going where are my caustic buddies going i hope they're
landing next to me really there's a pk here god damn it oh
my god which one's which one which caustic is which
all i hear is caustic I'll come over to them.
I can't tell.
Which casting is which?
The voices!
Oh no.
I'm coming back!
Juicy!
I got you, Juicy!
Wait, what if I flank?
Oh, I can't flank that.
Oh my god, I fucking knew it.
what the okay oh
nice the team was nice goodbye oh i feel like you could like
time it and everything too where the fuck is the oh pk in
the box oh wait i don't need that i got pk right here all
right today we're gonna play will she hit those our favorite
game guys
first team that got wiped too what the fuck
i mean sure oh my god he did a finisher on him all right
here we go he missed too i just realized the bangalore
fucking oh the bangalore missed the zip line
who is he alting that for oh whoops
Maybe he has my skin.
Guys, maybe he has my skin, guys.
Holy shit, that guy is crazy for that.
You're fucking crazy.
Open that door.
Oh shit, why?
Nice.
I mean, we can go in, right?
Holy shit.
What is going on in here?
What the fuck is going on?
How many days do those people have?
Oh my god.
The teammates are coming over, guys.
I don't feel so safe no more.
Okay.
Wait, did they leave?
Oh, they left.
probably aren't none it might be very risky to run two close
quarters but aren't none is aren't none okay i think the
double caustic is a little scary uh guys i understand now i
yeah no we literally gassed up the fucking house like that
that should break some code shouldn't it like didn't we
establish a geneva convention for something like this a real
thank you for this thank you for the twitch prize thank you
thank you
but what if triple caustic what the
oh i'm gonna wait i'm gonna wait
oh my god that's a full team
Birds have you.
Oh my god, again?
I did not expect him to do a round two in there.
Okay, that's...
I didn't expect a round two.
Oh my god, same.
We didn't know.
Please please please please
It's okay I got myself Hello guys Hello my fellow Cossacks I
need help My fellow Cossacks He's stupid
Oh, wait, did he go that way and he died for it?
Alright, it's fine.
What was that?
Oh, here.
Wait.
Oh, no.
There, I gave them a little treat.
What the?
What the fuck?
I don't think his teammate got the menmo.
I don't know if you saw that.
But, like, did you see that?
His teammate was like, we're fighting them, right?
Like,
yeah, they definitely did not get the breathing in.
I don't really have long range, so I'll be here.
Alright, that's fine.
Don't worry, I'm mapping you up.
Where are we shooting at?
What the fuck?
I don't think I can hit that.
Unfortunately, I can't.
Wee.
Look at you.
Can't even...
Oh.
Whoa.
I'm so rich.
Look at that.
Look at all that money.
Oh my gosh.
I wish I...
really want to grab it so bad i don't even know what those
balls do but it was shiny
it was so shiny wait i have an idea
oh my god please help me no that's okay okay
all good all good we're all good all good all good all good
all good grab this.
So it's like I never died.
Alright, now now I can do this.
And where the fuck is the scope?
I guess not.
Oh shit.
Alright, let me grab this real quick.
Is there no one behind us just in case?
Take a deep breath!
Please, it's so long!
It's okay, I have another self-rest!
Nice!
No need to use stealth for us!
But we do have to go.
Wait, can we break these windows, chat?
Are these windows breakable, guys?
Okay, here.
Oh, no.
We're, like, slowly going up.
Okay, we have to leave, though.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
That's not good.
Yeah, I had a feeling.
I was like, that does not feel like one team.
You think they'll let me...
Alright.
Yeah.
I was like, do you think they'll... Yeah.
Nice.
They did.
They did let me.
Alright.
30 we should get moving don't want to get toasted
hello what heard a fucking bow there's this guy right here
just fucking bowing
oh that's a little scary not a fan of that guys
oh i only have one shield cell left everyone and the other
team are all high ground okay wait is this in zone wait oh
we all do buddy oh no we all do oh yeah i heard about it
we're like where you go where the arc star window you like
crash the server i'm gonna be here i don't think we should
push up because we have
Oh, that's not good.
That's our last shield.
No more shield cells.
Oh, um, no more.
Oh, no more, guys.
We just gotta pray.
We just gotta pray now.
Ha ha ha!
Yeah.
We did it!
Still got it.
Okay, no, the double caustic is crazy.
The double caustic.
Let's go and again!
Another one!
And another one!
not told you put the r9 in my hand it's over it's looking
over got that r9
thank god thank god they led us third party
all right what did we grab now how many challenges did i win
from that i got five completed challenges need oh yo i
didn't do 500 oh my god i thought i did i did not it looked
like i did though it really did oh all right i'm gonna call
it here chat i'm a little tired now but i had a fun time
playing to them oh we had a good rival stream a fun apex
stream i was gonna go on overwatch too but i'm like i'm
tired we did a lot of streams like the last couple of days
um but thank you all for watching if you guys didn't know i
do have an anniversary uh skin right now uh you can get it
it's free by the way um um it's free it's only uh 4 000
points so it's right here that's me and it is sorry
overwatch sorry i forgot they took the two away uh but
that's me and you can play as uh watson you know the watson
skin that's me basically and all you have to do is just
complete the challenges that's really it so you can see the
uh you can see here uh the challenges here so just complete
the seven anniversary dailies uh and it should be you should
be good to go after that so there's several weeks of it and
by the time you finish all your challenges, you should be
able to, you should be able to get a Doki Bird Watson skin.
Some people were asking why Watson.
It was the very first skin, it was the very first character
I got that led me to get my first Apex Predator slash Top
500.
So I was a Watson player of my squad.
At that time, Watson was meta.
You had to have Watson in your rank squad.
And that was my character that I had to play to get me Top
500.
And so, you know, she took me there and that's why I
figured, you know, I figured to, it's like, it symbolizes,
like, my journey in Apex on how I got my first top 500.
But yeah, like I said, just complete the challenges, and
then, bam, you get the skin.
Thank y'all for supporting the stream today.
It's sponsored the stream today.
I will be back on Twitch tomorrow with the State of Play
Watch Align.
So remember to check me up there uh tomorrow uh here uh if
you guys want to support me the other means i my anniversary
merch is out right now i forgot to make i knew i forgot to
make one more command but also for those who don't know um
uh apex and i have a special collaboration uh plushie
collaboration at the at the moment so um you guys want to
this is like for only four weeks you can pre-order the
watson dokey bird plushie to celebrate the seventh
anniversary um uh and also my second year anniversary too um
this is a one-time thing so after four weeks the plushie
will not be made again so you want like a little moment
moment uh a little memory sake of the the this you know this
insane moment in my career uh in our career uh this will be
the time to pick it up to commemorate this exciting
collaboration we had with apex legends um other stuff other
stuff to show My newest cover song, Girlfriend, is out right
now on YouTube.
I said if I hit 800K views on that cover, I will make a
sequel, which it will be Skaterboy.
So, when you get 800K views, I'll work on Skaterboy from
Avril Lavigne.
But, yeah, you can do exclamation point song.
You can check out the music video.
What else?
You want to support me via other means?
Feel free to use my code on Gamersubs, EA, and Fortnite.
it's all dokeybird uh so i have a code for fortnite i have a
code for ea and i have a code for uh for uh ea fortnite
gamer subs so and it's all dokeybird um you want to know
whenever i stream on twitch please follow me on twitter
because i always tweet out whenever i stream on here and
also uh you want to check out more of my content my main
channel is youtube so please follow me on youtube you want
more of my content uh that's where my main channel is my
other content would be on Twitch, which is like bonus
content, but my main content is on YouTube.
And I'm trying to get a million subscribers.
So I really appreciate if you would check me out on YouTube
and give me a subscription.
Give me a subscription so we can get to a million
subscribers by the end of the year.
I guess that's everything to show.
I also have PUBG Tournament next week on Sunday and Monday,
and the main broadcast will be on my Twitch.
My POV will be on my YouTube channel.
Anyway, I think that's everything to show for.
Thank you all for watching.
Thank you all for the subs.
for the donations, for the follows, for the raids.
Thank you, everyone.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you suffer, me, head to bed, guys.
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.